during this entire interview it's best
to read between the lines of what lou is
saying as while ostensibly equivocating
he's actually saying quite a bit
breadcrumbs are judiciously dropped
tweet the hashtag ufo amnesty and i'll
retweet it at toe with kurt this is the
second interview with luis elisondo and
his longest interview ever luis elisondo
is a former us army counterintelligence
special agent mostly known as the
director of the now defunct a-tip a
program initiated by the defense
intelligence agency in order to study
unidentified aerial phenomenon also
known as ufos thank you to short form
for sponsoring this video and click on
the timestamp in the description if
you'd like to skip this intro for those
new to this channel my name is kurtz
mungle and i'm a filmmaker with a
background in mathematical physics
dedicated to the explication of what are
called theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but also
delineating the possible connection
consciousness may have to the
fundamental laws provided these laws
exist at all and are noble to us now
this ufo phenomenon may seem tangential
to the exploring of the variegated
landscape of toes that is theories of
everything however if you watch episodes
like the kevin knuth episode you'd see
that there's an intimate connection
between some of the deep mysteries of
the universe and this phenomenon thus
i'm interested and don't view this
enigma with the stigma that the majority
of the scientific community has if you
enjoy witnessing and engaging in
real-time conversation on the topics of
consciousness psychology physics and so
on then do click on the link in the
description for the discord and for the
subreddit there's also a link to the
patreon that is patreon.com
if you'd like to support this podcast as
the sponsors and the patrons are the
only reason i'm able to do this full
time and it would be extremely difficult
to explore topics like geometric unity
or loop quantum gravity or even string
theory which is coming up without the
sponsors without being able to do this
full time because of patrons like
yourself
again that link is patreon.com
kurtjmungle thank you regardless of your
decision as for the sponsors there are
three algo is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations planning
to avoid stockouts reduce returns and
inventory write downs while reducing
inventory investment it's a supply chain
ai that drives smart roi headed by a
bright individual named amjad hussein
who's been a huge supporter of the tow
podcast since nearly its inception in
fact amjad has a podcast about ai and
consciousness which will be linked in
the description so if you'd like to
learn more about that then you can
subscribe to his content as doing so
supports this content the second sponsor
is brilliant now brilliant illuminates
the soul of math science and engineering
through these bite-sized interactive
learning experiences with courses that
explore the laws that shape our world
the fundamental laws which elevate math
and science from something to be feared
to this delightful experience of guided
discovery you can even learn group
theory which is one of the most daunting
mathematical theories at least for
newcomers and it's one of the main
pillars behind the standard model that
is quantum field theory so when you hear
that the standard model is predicated on
su-2 cross su-3 across u1 that's the
same as well those are technically
called league groups visit brilliant.org
tow for free and get 20 off the annual
subscription i recommend that you don't
stop before four lessons and i think
you'll be greatly surprised that the
ease at which you can now grok subjects
that you previously had a hugely
difficult time understanding the third
sponsor is joining us for the first time
and that's short form which is a place
that you can go if you don't have the
time or the inclination to read an
entire book yet let's say you want to
know the gist of it so that you can be
conversant as if you've read it and i
mean that in the best sense more on
short form later quick note this podcast
is also on itunes spotify google podcast
and so on i hear many comments asking
where it is it's in the description if
you'd like to follow on an alternate
audio platform thank you and enjoy this
conversation one of the most revelatory
conversations with luis elisando to date
that's primarily thanks to you as this
was an ama that his questions were
gleaned from you thank you for watching
slash listening and thank you lou for
your generosity enjoy jennifer tell
jennifer
like i know how much my wife contributes
to
my success it's mainly my wife's success
so i imagine much of your success
absolutely correct kurt it is it is
absolutely it is it is um you know
behind i tell everybody behind every
great man is a greater woman uh
uh or a greater person you know writing
i mean obviously it might come from an
older generation but it you know it's
it's usually the success of anybody is
always dependent upon a close circle of
trusted people behind them uh that are
that are
you know really helping make things
happen so you're you're absolutely right
okay anything you want me to be aware of
before we go live anything you want to
say you know the rules man there are no
rules you know you can ask me whatever
you want
okay if you can see this
type
forgot about dre
forgot about dre
so lu while i'm making sure there's
about a 20 second delay before i can
tell if this actually went live how's
your day going
uh you know it's going uh
uh considerably well uh versus the
alternative right there's an old saying
any day above ground is a good day and
uh i definitely subscribe to that
i know that you're in such a whirlwind
primarily what is it interviews or what
no i wish um
it's a combination of many things you
know when i when i first presented that
those five slides um those
on on how we are having this
conversation legislative engagement
executive engagement
etc um all those take a lot of effort
every day a lot of care and feeding
they're like they're like children
really uh that are constantly uh wanting
attention and so you you have to to feed
the beast accordingly you have to make
sure you give
just the right amount of information um
to to to those specific
silos if you will or or pillars um you
know to to keep them happy
but of course
therein lies part of the challenge
because you can't give all sides the
same information necessarily because
obviously the information you talk to
with executive leadership
sometimes is classified and you can't
give that necessarily to the public but
you can still have the same conversation
without providing classified information
so that's you know that's how you have
to thread that needle and it's it's a
constant
i guess you could call it spinning of
plates um
and hopefully you don't drop drop any of
them and so it takes a lot of
a lot of time uh it takes a lot of
effort
and a lot of a lot of coordination for
each one of those this is what i don't
think people understand when you look at
the
the collective
achievements or accomplishments we
collectively have made all of us over
the last four years
each one of those bullets is is is
hundreds if not sometimes a thousand
hours
working behind the scenes to make things
happen um it's it's it's a lot a lot of
work and
you know i still have a day job
and uh i'm still you know trying to to
do my best to have this conversation
every time i have one of these these
interviews um then you can attest to
this card you know i don't get paid for
this you know you know yeah i mean i
don't
call me a liar but
have you ever paid me to do an interview
no
no right and i don't ask for one and i
won't accept it um for to do one uh like
like this so
um it takes time away from my other
stuff
it's uh it's a lot a lot of work but i
think it's worth it in the end i think
ultimately this is a conversation that
that needs to be had and i think we all
we all have a part of it
do these conversations make you nervous
uh
you know conversation doesn't make me
nervous people make me nervous
it's probably just a product of my my
upbringing and maybe my my choice of of
career profession
i think dialogue and conversation is
great you know it's funny you should ask
me that [ __ ] because there's a um
my wife and i
my wife jokes quite a bit with me and
and she
she sometimes don't know if i'm telling
if i'm being serious or not just because
of my sense of humor
and um you know i told her i said after
after
40 or 50 years around the sun
the one thing i've learned it's um you
know i i love humanity it's it's humans
i don't like you know and uh there's a
difference you know i love the idea of
humanity but unfortunately
individually as human beings um
you know there's uh i think there's a
lot of room for improvement for for all
of us to be honest with you so so there
lies the problem um to have a
conversation that's
concerning uh you know humanity i have
to engage you know humans
and and that's what that's what i find
challenging sometimes because
humans are uh we're emotional beings uh
we can be
we can be fragile beings and sometimes
we can be
um
we can be violent beings and and and to
each other and that violence can
manifest itself not just physically but
sometimes just in words and hatred and
so uh that's what i find so challenging
you know just simply trying to have a
conversation and there's people out
there that want to
want to stifle that conversation for for
whatever reason
okay well let's
minimize your trepidation by saying
anytime you need to refill your coffee
or go to the washroom people who are
watching just bear with us because we're
going on for quite some time so here's a
question from myself by the way i have
to ask what do you think of my coffee
cup right i know people are expecting
like machine guns and tanks and whatnot
right but
i have flowers to celebrate fall right i
have hearts there you go you beat me
okay
damn you kurt conspicuous for similar
reasons okay is there any evidence that
these
whatever we want to call them aliens
creatures
future humans whatever we want let's
label them x is there any evidence that
these x
can shapeshift can look like other
humans or other creatures
you know i i i don't know
but i'll tell you mimicry is is
something that is common in nature and
it's even common in what we do
there are species to defend themselves
in the animal kingdom let's take a coral
snake versus let's say a king snake the
coral snake is very deadly the king
snake um has the same colors except for
some of the the the color arrangements
are in opposite order um and and these
animals mimic other animals for
protection now let's look at it from a
humanistic perspective
um we have something where we call light
deception on for example navy ships in
the old days we would string lights in a
way that would try at night to make a
big large destroyer appear to be a uh a
fishing boat right a trawler uh and and
we we
light deception is is part of camouflage
part of survival so um if there is a a
species that is is far more advanced
than human beings
um it's not inconceivable look we can go
to the panda exhibit in in you know the
zoo in china
and see that zookeepers will often wear
these kind of i mean it appears
ridiculous to us but not so ridiculous
to the pandas um the zookeepers are are
required to wear a panda suit a big
furry uh teddy bear suit uh interesting
yeah they do that so when they go into
the enclosure to clean up the enclosure
or what not provide food um they don't
disrupt the the local panda population
as least as possible um you know of
course it's it's entertaining to us to
see a bunch of humans walking around in
furry panda suits but
but at the end of the day it's it's
effective so
um
you know i i don't think it's
inconceivable um you know the problem is
when we start going down the road of you
know you say shape-shifting and things
like that
immediately start going into the world
of woo
unquote and and paranormal and again
there's nothing wrong with it i've
written articles on on paranormal right
everything by by by definition in
science is paranormal until it becomes
normal uh frankly
so but the problem is that we
we don't have hard evidence we have a
lot of anecdotal evidence um a lot of a
lot of people report seeing things um
that these the uap can look like an
aircraft sometimes disguise itself like
a 747 or or that the
the occupants can can you know
make themselves look like human beings
um i i don't really know um
during our time at atip we were focused
primarily on the nuts and bolts of this
and uh you know what what our military
eyewitnesses and and collection
capabilities were telling us
at the time we didn't really have any
reports of quote
shape-shifting now cloaking that's a
different story
we do have some information that
indicates that these things do have an
ability
uh to try to evade some of our our
sensors
and and for example radar you get these
nonsensical what looks like spoofing
or radar jamming occurring um you have
uh
you know the low observability portion
of the five observables is is you know
that includes things like active
camouflage and cloaking and and
and again low observability it's hard to
see
um and so that
there is there is information that we
have that that pertains to that
okay speaking about cloaking is there
any evidence that suggests well ufos are
associated with orbs at least
anecdotally firstly what's the reason
for that and then second
is there any evidence that you know that
suggests that these orbs may be
more plentiful than we think perhaps
around us whether in homes or outside
cityscapes
just cloaked yeah the problem with orb
the word orb is is you're not going to
get a common definition from most people
everybody thinks an orb means something
else some people think an orb is a
little
plasma ball others say it's
much much bigger and intelligently
controlled
um you know orb is kind of a general
catch-all when you say is an orb related
to ufo well by definition it is a ufo
it's unidentified and it's flying or
it's a you know it's in our atmosphere
and uh
it's an object it's something we don't
know what it is so by definition an orb
is a uap but the question is is it a uap
in the sense that we we we're talking
about uaps whether lenticular type shape
or maybe a cylindrical shape or a
triangular vehicle
um i think the jury's still out there
does seem to be some information that
suggests that orbs as you call them are
sometimes
associated with other uap sightings that
there are uaps in the sky and then you
see these little balls of light
you know um
the problem is it's it's a very
generalized term
we now know for a fact
that things such as ball lightning are
real is that an orb well yeah at times
it looks like an orb to me um other
times when you have large
large amounts of energy being released
into into the atmosphere in the
environment let's talk about tectonic
movement for example
where these titanic forces uh right
underneath the surface of the earth um
creating this this this this
plasma effect in the atmosphere where
you get these different colors uh
shooting into the sky and and again orbs
if you will
um being reported and seen and even
captured on camera uh but that that's
that's an orb that that i think we can
all agree is probably um being
manufactured um naturally now are there
orbs that are intelligently controlled
well we did talk about that at atip you
know one of the questions where when you
look at the
the the the different shapes and sizes
of vehicles orbs tend to be almost like
a i guess in in in a vernacular sense
think of a uav
think of a drone
um the pro the the they tend to be
described as being much smaller highly
maneuverable uh different colors
sometimes red sometimes green sometimes
yellow sometimes blue
um is it possible that those colors are
are
are indicative of mission set right is
it
are the blue ones doing certain things
where the reds are doing something else
and their purpose is something else
where the yellows and whites are doing
something else
it's certainly plausible
you know i i i don't dismiss that at all
the problem is we just don't have enough
information because it appears that the
the
these orbs tend to be small that it's
really hard to argue the case that they
are being occupied by any type of
biological organism now it doesn't mean
that they're not it just means that you
know it
we haven't seen that yet um
you know we don't know what these are
these perhaps some sort of unmanned
reconnaissance
capability that are kicked out um
not much different than we use drones
ourselves right to do certain types of
reconnaissance missions um we don't know
it's certainly possible
the reasoning behind my question is that
tom delong
i recall was saying one shouldn't do ce5
i'm going to get you to explain what ce5
is but anyway one shouldn't do ce5 and
when one does it often orbs are
associated with it and one thinks oh
that's great because i'm inducing some
contact and tom said
be careful one shouldn't do that lightly
so that to me implies
that there's something nefarious or
potentially nefarious about these orbs
well i mean look i'd say the same thing
you know don't mess around with
electricity unless you're a licensed
electrician be careful because you can
get zapped that's true with anything
that's not just orbs that's electricity
that's swimming pools that's everything
um you know just
i can't speak for tom you know i don't
know what tom meant by that but i can
tell you that that
general word of caution i think is is is
appropriate for for just about anything
out there you know if you don't know
what you're getting into just
just be mindful um
you know
there are potentially things that go
bump in the night and and and it's not
all you know um necessarily uh good or
bad you know it's not all sunflowers
like your cup
well you know any time you go go
snorkeling look i'm an avid scuba diver
i've been scuba diving my whole life um
you know there's always a remote risk
when you go scuba diving in some of
these beautiful coral reefs you know
what there's a risk you're going to come
up against a shark now not all sharks
are going to do anything but if you're
carrying a you know a bag of of fresh
fish that you wound up spearing uh and
and are now bleeding out of this bag and
and dead um chances are you may attract
a lot more attention than just a curious
shark you may be attracting a hungry
shark and now you got to kind of pay
attention so
um
you know i i
i i think that's wise advice on just
about everything that we we
we we do you know i live here in wyoming
where a lot of people like to go go
splunking and and you know adventuring
into caves
but again you know you have to have the
right equipment be careful when you go
into a cave you know make sure you've
got light make sure you've got you know
gear that can get you in and out and
rope and whatnot
okay
now let's get to some of the audience
questions this one comes from
stephanie
stephanie highfill is there information
being recorded or being encoded into
less mainstream information media
channels that can be free that can be
parsed out john nash style like a
beautiful mind that could help us arrive
closer at the truth of this phenomenon
so i'm gonna need your help kurt kind of
detangling that question because i'm not
familiar with the reference but when
you're saying encoded um
can can you repeat that question one
more time i want to answer it i just
want to make sure i'm understanding the
question okay just deciphering
essentially with someone of sufficient
intelligence can decipher that there are
different drops being
placed by let's say disclosure people
the government
oh oh i see what you're saying
breadcrumbs what i refer to as
breadcrumbs and that one can decipher it
um
well you know i i've i've always left
breadcrumbs every interview i ever do uh
so for the last four years
you know i think people can now go back
through a lot of what i've said in the
past and come back and say oh
so that's what he was referring to now
we know uh because certain people have
come out whether it's you know jimmy
katz in his book or other folks
um
you know i i think
i can't speak on behalf of the
government and other people um i suspect
that
what what i can say is i i think that we
are at a point now where
um we don't have to leave the
breadcrumbs um
that that we have been in the past i
think i think the time has come for us
to be even a little bit more
straightforward and a little bit more
clear
you know uh the difficult part is when
you're dealing with security clearances
and ndas which everybody hates to hear
you know that's that's becoming a
three-letter word um that i think is is
probably going to be etched somewhere on
my on my tombstone and people are going
to be throwing tomatoes at it you know
uh from here to eternity because they
hate it and they don't they don't but
they hate it because they don't really
understand what it means and why you
have them
um you know those those ndas definitely
get in the way of having a complete
transparent conversation but i i also
think that that
we are having it i think where we we've
come a long long ways
and as far as answering this specific
question as far as leaving breadcrumbs i
can't speak for anybody else i don't
know precisely what the gov because the
government isn't just this one
huge uh if you a monolithic enterprise
it's it's comprised of people and and
those people each other's people have
their own interests and their own
desires and and their own agendas and so
i i can't speak for them i can only
speak for me
um
i think certainly if people were to look
at all the this talks i've given
uh and and really look at them and
listen to them closely they will see
that a a lot more has been said
than uh than than might necessarily be
acknowledged
okay this one comes from ross coldheart
since you left the dod
have you been warned not to talk
publicly about certain things and if so
what
yes
i have been warned uh
i've been warned first of all not to
disclose not to discuss classified
information um which i i've heeded uh
thus far and will continue to do so
um i've had uh i've had i've been
threatened there were individuals in the
pentagon that did not like what i do and
how i did it and so uh once secretary
mattis's um
public affairs officer dana white left
they started to change uh the narrative
a little bit um i was told that i would
be labeled crazy
and that they would come after my
security clearance
which they did
they actually did
try to do that
and they were
true to their word
but um fortunately i had some some
friends and allies that knew exactly
what i was doing beforehand and uh
you know it uh it wasn't quite so easy
for them to to be able to do that but
but to put it simply i i've been warned
so you've been warned have you ever
gotten in trouble ross has a sub
question have you gotten into trouble
for acknowledging that the us has
recovered non-terrestrial materials well
they're watching me very closely
they're trying there's elements that are
trying to get me into trouble
so that's why i walk a very fine line
i walk right up to that line but i won't
step over um because they're waiting for
me to screw up they're waiting me for to
sit there waiting for me to say one word
that i shouldn't say uh and in order to
use that against me and silence me um
so yeah i mean i've gotten trouble they
tried to come after my clearance like i
said um
you know and unfortunately i had to had
to seek legal counsel
uh to protect my constitutional rights
to do so um you know it seems that
they've backed off a little bit for now
but i'm not fooling myself i know that
there's there's still you know wolves
circling uh just beyond the the limit of
of of of the fire that i'm i'm standing
next to
uh waiting for an opportunity so i'm
very mindful of that but you know i'll
also say that there's some really good
elements i've had an opportunity you
know sometimes through the worst of uh
adversity you get a chance to see people
at their best
and i've learned that there are people
on the inside that really do want to
have a conversation and that want to see
things done right and these are senior
people some of these are very very very
senior people
and uh they have they were willing to
put their their professional careers on
the line to defend me
and protect me um and you know that
that means a lot that makes that makes
me feel makes me feel good because i've
always been that way you know i could
have called people out by name
three four years ago just to defend my
credibility and i never did
you know people are now realizing that a
lot of those people are now finally
coming out of the shadows
and you know my life could have been a
lot easier had i had i had i you know
called them out um to defend me but i
didn't because i made a promise to them
that i would never
i would never reveal their identities
until they were ready to do so
um and uh that's just the way i mean to
me principles
you know mean everything either either
you're a person of principle or you're
not um doesn't matter how bad the
the going gets you you you got to stick
by your word so
it's been a mixed bag for me um you know
make sure ross we tell ross here the the
the
the full story that and you know even
though i've had people coming after me
i've also had a lot of people rally
around me
and and to me i'd rather i focus on
those folks those are the folks that i
you know just makes you want to do this
even more because
you know they're willing to to get your
back and are you allowed to say those
folks
uh well they haven't come out of the
shadows yet they they're in the process
and um
we'll we'll let that play out but i
think it'll be quite obvious when they
step out because people are gonna go oh
that person oh my goodness
i didn't know that person was with liv
um you know
so i'll leave it at that another bread
another breadcrumb right
right right
there are many people who have super
chatted don't worry i'm going to get to
them i have a follow-up question to what
you just said which is there are wolves
that are watching you like a hawk
is there another reason outside of
national security that they they don't
want you to disclose what you
may disclose or they're worried you may
yeah i mean
what is their worry outside of them
there have been um
you know uh
forbidden truths we can call them if you
will
they've been forbidden truth in the
history of not just our country but many
countries
truths that could upset
a balance a balance that's been around
for a long time
let me give you case in point
[Music]
let's say there were some people that
were doing their job by running a ufo
program in the past
but because certain things happened
presidents were no longer briefed people
in congress were no longer briefed who
should have been and now they're running
an operation that's um
considered rogue but it's still an
important mission
um
[Music]
turns out you know all of a sudden now
let's say hypothetically the cat's out
of the bag
what's going to happen to those people
when when the government realizes they
were running operations for better or
for worse
um without any oversight without any
legal oversight right
what what
who who's going to be held accountable
for that the fact that they did not
brief legally like they were supposed to
certain members of congress and
committees and oversight committees and
and and their chain of command um that's
that's potentially criminal criminal
action
let's say i've said this before let's
say you have two competing companies you
have uh aerospace company a and
aerospace company b
and aerospace company a for whatever
reason gets a favor and some sort of
really exotic game changing material is
provided to that company to do us
analysis
meanwhile company b who is competing
fairly
doesn't uh doesn't get that material
turns out company a now starts getting a
lot of contracts defense contracts and
becomes a multi-billion dollar company
while company b who never had the
advantage of having that material
um
goes into bankruptcy people hundreds of
people lose their jobs and stockholders
lose their their investment
um keeping in mind that both companies
are supposed to be treated fairly and
have fair
competition
uh when it comes to us government
contracts now what now now what happens
where's the liability
and by the way now these companies are
are you know doing good things for the
united states
um but they got there because they had
an unfair advantage
competitive advantage
potentially again i'm not i'm not this
is hypothetical right
where's the liability there you're
talking to trillions and trillions of
dollars worth of liability
um
you know and and who made those
decisions to do that you know who's
going to be held culpable for that uh
you know security exchange commission
would not be very happy to know that
that to publicly company two publicly
traded companies that were competing for
a contract one had an unfair advantage
the other went bankrupt that's that that
that's a problem that's a real problem
and so you're talking about
big big money interests you're talking
about
things that are going into that gray
world that go beyond just government
interest you're talking about banking
you're talking about
um
you know
some of the biggest names on the planet
that have a lot to lose
or a lot to gain
in hindsight so you know i think we
always have to be careful that that
governments have always had um
interesting ties to to
to certain interests and that's true of
all governments it's not just the us
it's that's everybody
and we need to be mindful of that you
know because you could you could be
you could be um
putting some people in a very
uncomfortable position and i'm aware of
that and that's why i've been very
delicate how i approach this topic i'm
not trying to beat anybody up
i'm not trying to expose anybody and and
say ahaha gotcha see there um i'm trying
to have the conversation in a
collaborative meaningful way where where
everybody wins nobody has to get burned
right it's not a zero-sum game i'm not
hypothetically do they view it like that
like there's a potential where everyone
can win or do they view it somewhat zero
well i can't i can't speak for them i
can't tell you what they think all i can
tell you is what i think and and my
approach and my approach is to say look
guys
you know we're not trying to expose
anybody this is not true i'm not trying
it's not a witch hunt you know despite
what you may see on social media where
everybody wants their pound of flesh
that's not going to get us anywhere we
we need to to
we need to be adults about this and we
need to have a a conversation that if
you really want the truth to come out
you better be able you better be willing
to compromise
you know this is we're not going to
we're not going to sit there and put
people to be eaten by the lions
just to just to satisfy someone's you
know ego or or or beef that they might
have with somebody else
um you know the truth is more important
than that this is not about
uh see i told you so or or
being vindicated this this is about
having a conversation that's that that
can affect all of humanity and we have
to be willing to
to set aside some of that uh if you will
um
[Music]
and understandably so you know you've
got lots and lots of decades worth of of
people covering this up i know there's a
lot of animosity and resentment as a
result of that by people saying you know
you've been lying to us for all this
time but
but we got to be willing to put that
aside if we really want to move forward
in my opinion
you're referring to animosity from the
general public or animosity from some of
these wolves no general public who who
who want their pound of flesh because
people have been covering this topic up
for too long knowing that it's real men
lying to the american
people potentially how long is too long
when
potentially is it centuries
is it decades
well you know there's information that
goes away i live here in wyoming and i
live next to
members of the crow nation
and if you've ever had a chance to to
talk and really engage with indigenous
people first of all they're very very
private
two
they have an incredibly rich history
their their oral oral traditions and
oral history
doesn't go back a few hundred years um
it goes back millennia in fact when
when europe was facing its dark ages and
and
mankind almost went extinct in the
european continent and we were burning
books
you know indigenous people over here
were experiencing a golden era
that wasn't the case over here
and the way they look at nature the way
they look at
this topic uap is not like we look at it
through western eyes
in fact they don't view it as a threat
at all in fact they don't view it even
as paranormal they view it as as normal
as part of
of nature their natural environment as
real as the the lakes and the sky and
the trees on the mountains are
um and it's just accepted as part of
part of the greater universe
and you know i think i think there's
some beauty there um
you know they're not held hostage by
their by their fears
in fact they they embrace it yeah
and and that goes to show that that you
know you don't have to view this topic
as an either or it doesn't have to be
viewed as a threat
or as uh you know um some sort of of um
saving uh
opportunity for our species um it could
just be a natural part of our existence
um again do i subscribe to that
i don't know but i certainly i
i certainly think it's another way
another perspective that we should
consider um if that is the case and and
they're right then we've been dealing
with this for millennia i can tell you
that um
having a chance to talk to some people
in the vatican
you know they describe these these
flaming roman shields in the sky that
would follow them from from battlefield
to battlefield what they call the
eclipse which is the shape of the roman
shield
you know that's documented that's there
in fact i think if i'm not mistaken i
haven't read it from jacques valley uh
but from my understanding jacqueline
even wrote a little bit about that um
but i've seen that evidence myself there
there is
there is documentation
of these strange things in the sky going
back a long long time so i don't think
it's necessarily modern um
maybe our understanding is is a little
bit more advanced and may be considered
that modern but i don't think we're
dealing with a new phenomenon i think we
may be dealing with a new recognition
and perhaps hopefully at some point a
new understanding but i don't think this
is a new phenomenon to mankind i think
we've been faced with this phenomenon
for quite some time
you mentioned millennia which is
thousands of years i'm wondering
potentially tens of thousands
potentially millions or do you think
it's cut off around 9000 or so
well that's that's hard to tell because
we only as a species homo sapiens sapien
have been around roughly for a hundred
thousand years
and we only really gotten into written
language in the last five six thousand
years really
um and been gone from you know uh hunter
gathers to more of an agrarian type
society organized society which is if
you take a hundred thousand years and
you
compare the last five thousand years
really only the five five percent of our
entire time rummaging around this planet
has been in somewhat of a civilized
fashion um
you know and then if you look at that to
the context of it's been you know only
in the last
you know thousand years two thousand
years we we understood you know the
archimedes steam engine right and really
didn't even fully appreciate it until
the industrial revolution just a couple
hundred years ago
so now you're talking at you know point
two percent of mankind's time on earth
um
we we've been industrialized we've been
civilized
so how much of our own history do we
really know well you know we can go back
5000 years
pretty easily
um 8 000 years things start to get a
little murky right and anything much
beyond that
we really have no clue about and the
question is have we as a species been
aware of this
phenomenon much longer well
let's look at what we do know um you
know the general consensus is that the
the
american population let's say american
army united states i mean north america
south america central american
population
really began about 20 000 years ago with
during the land bridge when you had a
migration coming over the land bridge
and settling this part of the planet but
in reality it turns out now that a lot
of scientists believe that there were
many migrations and many migrations
before
that primary migration 20 000 years ago
in fact there may have been multiple
migrations going back perhaps even 100
000 years ago
so um is it possible that that our our
society um was aware of these things
maybe even interacted with these things
in a certain fashion i'm sure it's
possible absolutely it's possible i mean
most of our history we have no idea
about
you know it's it's like it's it's like
spending an entire day and having
amnesia except for the last five minutes
before you go to bed you know right how
was i what was i doing what did i eat
who did i speak to
what did i say
what i'm wondering is what you're
referencing is written history and i'm
curious about archaeological evidence
that you're aware of ah
or that potentially exists it's
interesting
yeah so let me give you a real world
example and i'm not gonna either defu
refute or or defend it but again i live
here in wyoming um and there is a
legend here called the little people the
pyori mountains um and for generations
the the indigenous people have reported
uh what appeared to be this fearsome
pygmy warrior tribe of humanoid type
creatures that lived in the mountains
and for many many many years it was
completely um considered a myth
folklore right yeah
and it turns out that scientists began
uncovering
artifacts up in the mountains
that
to some degree reinforced the notion
that there was some sort of
small hominoid type creature
living in the mountains
they found uh small tools they found you
know
small bones
um
that appeared to be be coming from some
you know human human human like creature
now i don't know i don't know the
details uh thoroughly i haven't had a
chance to really really explore it or
study it
but that part is true
that that people are now beginning to
look back and say well wait a minute um
is that possible because we're starting
to find archaeological evidence
um
so
you know
it's it's interesting here i can walk up
into the bighorn mountains
and they're pulling out spearheads
spearheads that are 11 000 years old now
think about that for a minute 11 000
years old
if that spearhead could talk what people
did it come from what were they hunting
what did this place look like you know
environments change in the blink of an
eye look at the sahara desert in 5 000
years you know there was a lot of
wildlife living in the sahara region
before it became a desert and and that
was in recent human history by the way
we were inhabiting the planet when that
happened
there are drawings on the side of rock
walls that illustrate uh um
alligators crocodiles if you will and
and animals that live not just on the
savannah but in the wetlands uh all
cohabitating there
so so this earth is very dynamic
every time we have a you know for us it
seems like a long time but every time we
have an ice age every roughly 10 15 000
years
the entire topography of earth changes
the climate changes animals change
people change right
um
you know i think it's i think it's very
possible that that there is potentially
some sort of archaeological evidence the
question is would we recognize it if we
saw it
and that's another big big question we
have to ask ourselves
you know um let me ask you this as a
scientist kurt
if i said to you um
kurt you have a task
um you can make it out of whatever you
want any material you want your goal is
to
in a million years
you have to create something now that
will last a million years to prove you
were here
what would you do how would you do it
think about it go ahead
no no no no let's do let's let's i love
you man but we're gonna we're gonna have
this mental exercise right now
i think it's important and by the way
it's not a trick question and i'm not
playing gotcha just what would you give
me just some examples that you might
throw out there to say okay i would make
something out of this or out of that
there are some meta materials that seem
to be harder than diamond so whatever is
our hardest material it would be made
out of that also just so you know i
don't classify myself as a scientist
i i'm more of a hobbyist let's say so
that's what i would do
so you'd find some sort of hard material
that would outlast just about anything
else on earth right where would you put
material where would you put it
orbit is one place
okay and hopefully a non-retrograde
orbit right so geosynchronous and
hopefully nothing would perturb it in a
million years chances are something
would but okay hypothetically in orbit
good
um
you know here on earth
it's really hard to make anything that
lasts more than a few thousand years you
can even make the pyramids and look at
them now and say wow those things are
5 000 years old and you know they don't
look so great and probably in another 5
000 years they're not going to look good
at all and they might last eventually
till a hill of you might have a little
hill of sand in a hundred thousand years
but that's going to be about it and
that's made out of rock right much more
same thing it's going to be gone in 10
000 years you won't probably even
recognize it'll be too worn um even
mountains in millions of years become
deserts right uh time moves on uh then
you have the subduction zones of earth
that eventually if you wait long enough
on the on the surface of the planet it
all gets recycled anyways it's all going
to get you know sucked down into the
mantle and get spit out the other end
and as new land so
so nothing is indelible
on this planet it's it's constantly
changing and and to create something
that can last the the sands of time so
to speak
is a lot harder than one might think you
know the few examples we have here on
earth
uh that are man-made you can look to the
pyramids you can look at things um
like uh stonehenge
but that's a blink of an eye
that those aren't the though that those
were just made
a few thousand years ago and they're not
going to be around um
you know for for a whole long a lot of
time that's just not the way earth is so
if we're trying to find some sort of of
some sort of marker
chances are you're not gonna find it
buried in the earth unless it only
happened maybe the last five thousand
years ago or so
right even some of the most most
dramatic examples of terraforming let's
look at for example uh the meteor impact
crater in arizona happened 60 000 years
ago
that's already filling in
you know in another hundred thousand
years from now you may not even know
anything ever happened
because of the processes of earth and
what this planet does
it's constantly erasing
what's on the surface and it's
constantly burying what lies beneath
deeper and deeper and deeper until
eventually you know
it gets recycled so
um
you know
it's that's that's a hard question you
know
what would last long enough for us to go
back and say wow this is an indicator of
alien life on this planet 100 000 years
ago
what would you have to do
to to achieve that to accomplish that
it's a lot harder than one might think
and then again would you recognize it
one might say well dna dna is a perfect
example if you wanted to
to do something that was enduring for
humanity that we could look back a
hundred thousand years ago say yes that
was absolutely manipulated by an
intelligent life form well
deoxyribonucleic acid
may be one way to do it you can put
coding and sequencing in there that will
perpetuate over time and time and yes
you'll have some degradation over
generations but but in essence you could
do something that way and basically it's
a biological marker right
so we have to be careful when we say we
look for for evidence because evidence
isn't just necessarily
a spearhead found in the bighorn
mountains from 11 000 years ago it's not
necessarily a pyramid sitting in the
middle of the desert
it could be far more sophisticated than
that you said put it in orbit right well
what if if we put that rather than orbit
we put into the human body
you know
so
anyways that's that's that's so i know
it's a very long-winded way to answer
that question yeah let me ask a quick
follow-up and then we'll get to super
chat questions audience questions and so
on
are there places that we should be
looking for evidence that you feel like
we're not so for example i mentioned
archaeological investigation sites the
reason i brought that up is some people
say craft were found okay but you're
also saying there may be other markers
maybe possibly
biologically for example you know um
near earth celestial bodies like the
moon where you don't have atmospheric
friction you don't have the that you
don't have the tectonic processes that
we have here on earth that are
constantly recycling you know
you know someone might want to put
something on the moon um if you wanna
you know reminiscent of um
what was it uh 2001 space 2000 space
2001 space odyssey right where you have
these these monolithic
markers
um
that's certainly one way to do it you
know you could put something uh where
you don't have those those same
um
those same processes occurring where
maybe you you could you might be able to
extend your time twice as long for
leaving some sort of archaeological
evidence um
the evidence could be right here could
be right in front of us could be within
genetic sequencing uh it could even be
more obvious than that it could be very
fact that we're alive and we're on this
planet
is is an example of of in some
intelligent life somewhere making a
decision that life needs to exist on
this planet we need to be open to all of
that we really do i think
we need to cast a very wide net and this
is why we say all options have to be on
the table until they're not on the table
because you might be surprised um
something that's super super intelligent
probably isn't going to build a pyramid
that's only going to last you know
20 thousand years they're gonna do
something that's far more enduring
something that will really be you know
no kidding you know uh
maybe not understand
all right this question comes from terry
ruckert
mr i gotta ask real quick kurt i don't
mean all right what what forgive me and
i know i'm gonna get a lot of hate for
this what is a super chat i hear it a
lot what what's a super chat
well the super chat is when someone pays
five dollars fifty dollars a hundred
dollars sometimes most of these are five
to ten dollars you'll get your check
don't even say that because people are
gonna believe it okay okay
clear the record baby yeah yep yep i'm
not getting paid a penny for this
i'm kidding i'm kidding everyone okay
and thank you so much for supporting
thank you so much for supporting this
podcast i
tremendous i appreciated a tremendous
amount
it's not easy to do this full-time and
this is like this is a place where i
have almost no knowledge in louis you
could probably tell by the
by the
the
sophomoric nature of my questions kurt i
don't think anybody does you're not
alone brother you think i do you think
if i have all the answers don't you
think
we'd be where we are today no i've got
more questions and answers but that's
okay
you know my fears when people say they
do have all the answers those are the
people that i don't i don't trust
because i know they don't you know i've
been in this for a long time for the us
government and i damn sure don't have
all the answers you know so
no don't don't worry about it okay let's
get to the super chat by terry terry mr
elizondo has called the uap craft
multiple times made comments about not
knowing who is piloting them this seems
like an assumption at least without
proof does this mean there is proof
let's call that evidence because proof
in science doesn't exist that these are
craft with pilots
well
let's break it down craft um
craft is a is a noun it's a it's a
physical object um that allows the
transportation of of something from
point a to point b
um whether it's a hovercraft right or a
spacecraft or an aircraft um you know
it's it's a vehicle um
you know and so what defines a vehicle
well physical material
there's there's something to it nuts and
bolts
um i've made a very clear already my
opinion about um
my my my assertion that there is
material that is related to this topic
that has been recovered
um in the past that's that's all i can
say about that but that's why that's why
i use the term craft um it's it's a
maybe not the best term but to me it's
it's fairly accurate at least until i
can find another term that's more
accurate
as far as piloted or manned um
i'm not sure man is the right way to
way to
say because you know
that means there's a human behind it and
i'm not sure that's the case
but being piloted uh or intelligently
controlled
well the way they maneuver the way they
respond to us um think of in the
scientific world stimulus versus
reaction
we can provoke
and illicit responses from these things
so you know dave fravor said when i came
in and to close the gap on this thing
this thing reacted to me first of all it
pointed at me and then it maintained a
safe distance and mirrored my mirrored
my my maneuvers um so
there is some sort of intelligence
behind it that's not random that's not
that's not brownian movement right that
is that is
that's a deliberate action
there's justification in calling it
craft other than yeah that there may be
correct
and something or someone is is making a
decision how these things perform and
react so i think it's fair to say that
there is some they are intelligently
controlled
craft of some sort now much beyond that
um
you know i think i think that's that's
up for debate
are there potential photos that exist
that show
occupants
in some of these quote unquote craft
well there's a lot of photos that show a
lot of things the question is are they
real are they legitimate um
you know
are there potential photos that have
potentially deemed as legitimate that
have that quality
um
there are very compelling photos out
there that seem to show something inside
some sort of occupancy
and i'll leave it at that because it
it's it's it gets really murky much
beyond that
um
and there's a lot that can can be
speculated and so i try to avoid
speculation as much as possible but yes
um i've spoken to enough people
first-hand knowledge that that
um not only report the crafts that we we
know exist but but potentially
some sort of of uh
intelligence inside these these vehicles
he's mentioned it gets a murky murky as
in low resolution or murky what do you
mean by murky
i mean in every every aspect
the source of the information how the
information was obtained under what
circumstances
um resolution of photographic evidence
all of it
and so that's why we have to be very
careful
okay
this question comes from james shamsie
ross coldheart said it would be good to
offer a deal to those who kept the
program secret
they get some immunity in exchange for
getting us the truth i think he
referenced truth and reconciliation
would you guys go back
would you guys back a change.org style
petition for this do you think that the
others would like it absolutely i think
ross is 100 correct i think we need to
offer amnesty
uh from from criminal civil prosecution
um
if we want uh you know them to come out
of the shadows um
you know there there's a lot of pressure
right now
and i'm sure they don't uh whoever's
part of that cabal doesn't appreciate
that type of pressure and so if we could
offer some sort of uh yeah truth and
reconciliation i think i think something
to that effect would be very helpful in
this cause and say look
uh we're not gonna label you in fact
we'll give you anonymity and and
confidentiality uh what we'll do is
we'll
if you provide us this information we'll
make sure that kind of like a witness
protection program except for you know
no one will ever know you were part of
this except for very few people
um
i i think that's a great idea
i think i think that's what we should be
doing
you know ross suggested
in the previous interview a hashtag
called nasa tell the truth and so we ran
with that and part of that was
tongue-in-cheek
but then it had me wondering well what
would be an effective way of getting
this information disclosed quicker and
more truthfully
well nasa look you guys
it's working nasa is now starting to
have conversations and and the director
of nasa himself is beginning to to
entertain questions about about this
topic so
so you know i i think that's great i
don't think that's tongue-in-cheek at
all it's working um you know i'd give
yourself a big pat on the back because
i just saw a headline two days ago where
he's talking to talking with abby loeb
and they're going to be having this
conversation so
you know hey look don't look now but you
just achieve part of what you're trying
to achieve
thank you lou
what what would you recommend
what's another avenue
so storm area 51 is a horrible idea
yeah yeah you're going to get a bunch of
young kids in trouble and and
potentially really hurt this person
james
recommended a change.org petition truth
and
is also recommended by ross what do you
see as an efficient i think we also have
to start continuing to take an active
role in our politics and voting people
in who want transparency
we have been victimized too long
by our ignorance we have allowed people
to get into the government
that don't have our best interests at
heart
that are motivated by politics and not
diplomacy
and
where information is traded like a
commodity and so secrecies is
is something that is abused for the
wrong reasons and i think that's that's
problematic
there are some some points of light
right now in congress we see
between senator harry reid which is
absolute american hero you have on the
other side of the aisle marco rubio you
have congressman gallego and tim
burchette
and and walker and and some other folks
now finally coming out and saying hey
enough's enough um that's that's
fantastic that that's that's how you
make a difference and and
and making sure that the general public
goes to them and and encourages them and
tells them you know thank you for doing
this um
that goes a long way you know these
people are taking a huge risk to have
this conversation
and the more they hear from the public
that it's okay to pursue this
the more willing they're gonna be be to
do it and to have the conversation
and it's working i just came back from
dc myself i'm not gonna say who i spoke
with but
but that goes a long way that that means
a lot to them and
it gives them the motivation
in the top cover to start asking hard
questions and start poking the executive
branch in the chest and saying all right
what do you know about this and oh by
the way secretary of the air force
kendall with all due respect they'll
come back and say it's not a priority
just because you know we can't prove
it's a threat or not that's like saying
a submarine pops out of the
potomac river next to washington dc and
because it's not wearing an american
flag and you don't know if it's a threat
it's not a priority that's the wrong
answer um you know that's that's
again with all due respect to secretary
kendall unless we forget who you work
for it's not up to you to decide what is
a national priority
let me remind you it's not your air
force it's our air force and you're
doing a job we told you to do and if you
don't want to do it or you are or unable
to do it then we'll find somebody else
who can and you can go back to doing
what you're doing before
that's
that's my word of advice you know i i
paid my dues in the trenches and i
i know what i what i swore to do and
uphold
sometimes
sometimes people in positions of of
power need to be reminded of that
by the people by the way so that's what
you guys can do
okay so right now we've covered some
topics like consciousness ufos remote
viewing skinwalker all topics that would
make the traditional skeptics scoff
however it may be that there's a
paradigm shift coming short form has
compendious book summaries on the topics
of ufos consciousness science philosophy
spirituality and the meta issue of
anomalous data leading to radical
reorientations of current scientific
understanding such as thomas coons the
structure of scientific revolutions
which is by the way the short form book
i've read most recently how many of your
books on kindle are left essentially
unread how many bookmarks or tabs do you
have that you have to bookmark later and
those remain unread short form makes
learning what you've already wanted to
learn an eminently trivial task that can
be done fairly quickly also refreshing
books that you've read in the past is
efficiently done via their summaries
they even have exercises which prompt
you for retention because there's very
little use in accumulating knowledge if
it's going to be forgotten later to get
a free five-day trial visit
shortform.com
t-o-e that is toe and you'll also get 20
off the annual subscription at least for
the next 500 people so perhaps you want
to pause this video and visit them their
extremely clean ui makes it wonderfully
delightful to read and i have a
taxophobia which means that i find this
to be an underrated facet that i haven't
seen in virtually any other place
dan zetterstrom of the ufo podcast and
the link to his podcast will be in the
description his and andy's asks great
guy by the way he's doing a lot of great
work that's why great great lead in by
the way because you're asking what can
you do that's a guy who's and like what
you're doing is exactly what you guys
should be doing great great
a tip focused on military encounters did
you ever come across cases where people
had experienced high strangeness similar
to that found on skinwalker ranch for
example
have any pilots reported things like the
hitchhiker effect you know
what a great question and i know
[Laughter]
oh my goodness i'm gonna have to buy uh
buy dana beer for that one um
great for by the way he's putting me on
the spot and and uh you know that's
that's that's that's a great question
um
i want to answer this as accurately as i
can without without
without um giving anybody the wrong
impression
uh
there's a reason why the six observables
biological effects
okay um
that by definition is high strangeness
um
people after an encounter
experiencing
[Music]
certain
physiological and psychological
uh um
thinks
um
again i i i let me let me
to put it succinctly yes
but not
not the same
as as the skinwalker ranch um
differences being
well you know the skinwalker was looking
at a lot of the the the paranormal
aspects um
as you say in the vernacular you know
shape shifters and
uh i guess i think it was but once it's
ghosts and and
you know
poltergeist that type of activity
whereas atip was looking at nuts and
bolts ufos
um
but there there were some some some
parallels
some people
uh and the question the problem is we
don't know
we really don't know enough about that
um
about the uap
issue to really to really speak cogently
on that um people have had biological
effects and that's just that's as far as
we were prepared to go at the time
because that could be quantified and
qualified you can look at physiology and
morphology and you can look at things
like that and you can look at at tissues
and things like that you can quantify
and qualify
the other stuff is a lot harder
especially anything dealing
with with the you know a psychological
episode when i say psychological i mean
in a bad way not like it's made up i
mean
everything we do is interpreted
psychologically right
there's a mental process that goes along
with it with a physical experience
ptsd is a perfect example ptsd is very
very real but it's a psychological
uh response to a to a physiological and
emotional type of situation
and uh very much the same way you know
people people will will process data
differently
just like ptsd
uh
and and no different in this topic you
know you have people in some cases i've
talked to who
like dave fraver just wants to get
behind the wheel one of these things
learn how to fly it
then you have other people who've been
been deeply and emotionally impacted by
this and still carry that with them for
whatever reason they've they've come up
close and personal and um you know it's
caused uh
it caused some sort of conflict
internally i'll tell you a great guy
it's a super super guy
um
he was on one of the episodes of uh
of unidentified and he he he carried the
secret around he he told us chain of
command he was up in canada doing a
a uh a maneuver with the united states
and him and his buddy uh were were
situated fairly close to each other um
guarding some you know enema field like
a depot out of middle of nowhere and and
encountered a ufo well
they go to report it um
but his buddy recants the story and says
no it's all made up because of the the
the backlash that they received
and and he always maintained the story
and he was he was left out in the cold
people thought he was crazy and he
carried that around for a long long time
until one day
his buddy come out and and vindicate him
he says you know what
because i talked to the guy he said it
was real every bit of it i was there but
uh i didn't want to catch crap any
longer so i recanted the story and and i
left my friend out there to
to to flap in the wind so to speak
and
um you know it i that caused a lot of a
lot of
i'm sure a lot of issues imagine you
know being part of something
extraordinary and then
uh
the person that saw with you telling the
world nah
you know we're just kidding we didn't
really see it and you know you did and
have to carry that for 20 30 years only
to come back later his name is dave
marceau uh he's a great guy if you ever
get a chance to meet him i highly
recommend you have him on your show
he carried that around his you know in
his soul for for for decades
and um you know you you should ask him
the type of of
uh
emotional cost
uh
it it took on him um you know people
call you crazy people call you a liar
people call all sorts of things
only at the end to find out that you
know what you were right
and it did happen
and the witnesses were coming on us
saying yeah it did happen um
you know that yeah there's there's you
know you say hitchhiker effect i i
you know some folks
swear that once you have one of these
encounters there's there's this
hitchhiker effect and
and now all of a sudden
all sorts of weird things start
happening to you and your family
um
you know there's an individual that i
that i i'm very very very close to who
is very senior in this effort
who at some point when it comes out of
the shadows you should probably have
this conversation with that person
um
because they'll tell you absolutely yes
but
you know again i
i don't have any data that can be
quantified or qualified so i
i cannot speak definitively on it i
think we have to remain open
um
that you know there's a whole lot of
things that are possible
and i know you said you don't have data
that's quantifiable but i'm curious
about this hitchhiker effect or the
sixth observable is that associated with
proximity to the craft or length of time
looking at the craft like another
variable damn what is associated with a
great question man um
let me take a pass on that for now i'll
let me
that will be addressed um
sure we'll get to
great question
thank you we'll get to scott larkin
who says
there's some latin and then says lou i
believe your service to god and country
will be understood more clearly in the
history books are you aware of the cia's
paper known as adam and eve event the
adam and eve event how much of what is
going on is currently related to this
pending event
i've heard of it but i don't know
anything about it um
i've always made it very clear up until
recently i really haven't done much
reading on this
because i never wanted to have any type
of bias um even even subconsciously
people get mad at me well you know
didn't you read this report didn't read
that report look i i read government
reports man that's what i did that was
my job
and i didn't want to muddy the waters by
you know
all these other things out there you
know there's a lot of stuff that's
interesting there's a lot of stuff
that's crap you know there's a lot of
conspiracy
bs out there that's just nonsense and
garbage
and then there's some stuff that's you
know
pretty pretty accurate um
so i i i've heard of the adam and eve um
if you will uh but i'm not um i'm not
i'm not overly familiar with it so it
wouldn't be really good for me to
comment because i i don't know the
details of it now if you can paraphrase
for me i can
give you my opinion on it um are you
aware of kurt of that no i was going to
get you to explain to the audience as
well as myself
yeah i'm not i wouldn't be the guy to do
that okay so scott if you want please
paraphrase it and then let's get back to
it
someone wants to know for those who
maybe don't know what's the main
difference between awsap and atip what
involvement if any did you have with
awesome well now i can talk about it
because you know the guy came out um so
uh
jim mccaskey is a great guy um super
smart i've always said he's probably the
greatest
rocket scientist our government had at
the time um incredibly brilliant
gentleman
um and also was one hell of a risk taker
um
so asap think of ford motor company uh
as ossap
and they make a lot of models they make
uh you know the bronco they make the
crown victoria they make the mustang
think of atip as the ford mustang it is
a sub model built under within the ford
plant uh and it's a sports car um it's
one of the many different lines there's
that word sports car again
sports car right bob lazar reference so
what happens with osap when think of a
ford motor company eventually going out
of business for whatever reason
but the ford mustang is so popular that
the ford mustang continues to be built
under its own moniker
and continues to be built as the ford
mustang but there are no other there's
there's no other cars now being built by
the by the by the beginning so the baby
of and the parents died
uh it's yeah so it started off look
there would be no a tip without all sap
and without jim lecaski that's a fact
but when that program
went away a-tip continued and that's why
you have all the videos
out there from the roosevelt and all
these other incidents that will be
coming to light and continue to come to
light because a lot was done under a-tip
but it was military-focused only we did
not do civilian information they're
always military focused
and um you know we we did have funding
um i'll leave it at that you know i'm
not gonna
i'm not gonna say anything to disparage
my my good friend jim jim jim
uh is a good man and he's done a lot for
this country um
but you know i i can't speak for asap i
can only and i've said that from day one
as you noticed i've always said you know
i can't speak for ossap one day that guy
will come forward and hopefully we can
stand shoulder to shoulder and he'll
finally get the credit that he deserves
um but uh you know ostep wasn't a tip
and atip wasn't asap you know i was it
was a tip he was awesome and uh if you
want to know more about you know the
awesome stuff you probably have to ask
him
okay now you mentioned the word wu quite
a while ago
and just so you know i don't
firstly i don't use that word because
that word is used disparagingly
and also because much of what's
considered pseudoscience becomes science
and also what you categorize as being
paranormal depends on your assumptions
of what normal is and we don't have a
theory of everything so it's difficult
to say
given that
what's your opinion on remote viewing
and i believe you dabbled in that so i
would like to know
well i just like to know more about that
okay so remote viewing
is a
is defined as a human cognitive
capability to
observe things separated by space and
time in essence
i'm not going to discuss
what
i've done in my my career i've done a
lot of things in my career for my
country
most of it as you probably agree has
never seen light of day and it's not
really german or relevant to to this
discussion of uap the uap topic is only
one aspect of my career and my service
to my country um
but the rest is private unless you know
it doesn't need to be
um i don't think uh a discussion on on
remote viewing has anything to do with
with uaps or my time in the ata program
and i think it's just a distraction
um
and uh i'll i'll leave it at that
okay so this question comes from aof a
wafsol with the phenomenon being so
evasive what level of confidence do we
have that global disclosure will be a
net positive for engagement with it as
an analogy we know hornets exist but
poking the hornet's nest is ill-advised
can you repeat that kurt one more time
that's that's i think that's a really if
i get getting it right that's actually
really really interesting question so a
with seoul asks with the phenomenon
being so evasive what level of
confidence do we have that global
disclosure will be a net positive for
engagement with it
as an analogy we know hornets exist but
pokey the hornet's nest is ill-advised
well let's define engagement is
engagement the same as poking um i don't
think so
international engagement is getting
everybody on the same sheet of music
about the topic it's not necessarily
uh being provocative it's not
necessarily poking quote unquote the
hornet's nest
what it is it's an acknowledgment that
the hornet's nest exists
and that hornets exist so we should
probably understand them
i'm not i'm not uh at all advocating
that we go and poke the hornetsness what
i'm advocating is that we need to study
the hornet and we need to study where
the hornet lives and how it lives and
its relationship to its environment and
ultimately it's a relationship to us if
any i think the last time we spoke about
trans medium that it would go from water
to air
back and forth
is there any evidence of trans medium
with respect to rock can it move through
solid material
i've heard people speculate that we
haven't seen that but there are some
there were some scientific models
specifically a couple calculations um
that i was privy to in math mathematics
specifically
that indicate if you can get a certain
number below a zero then then
quote unquote it can cut through through
rock like butter
but
i
i don't i'm not i'm not a math expert
and i'm certainly not going to validate
or verify that because i don't know all
i saw were a bunch of numbers and
letters of the alphabet put in front of
me in a very
long strain of what you know i presume
to be valid equations um but i
i i don't know you know math for me was
a minor i think i got up to calc 3 and
um
you know true story i'll share this with
you um sure you know i i
i appreciate math and and love certain
aspects of math but i'm not necessarily
great at math um
and uh finally i wasn't going up to calc
3 and my professor um my professor
failed me the first time around
so i had a chance to make it up and i go
back to the same professor and by the
way my professor really didn't like me
very much and really i didn't take i
didn't take it as seriously as i should
okay um
and so um
time and time again i'd come in and i
wouldn't do good on the tests and uh
finally i i told him i said look um
i'm i'm having trouble here with this
class she says yeah you are and he said
look you're not really a really good i
don't think this is for you that you're
not a great student in in cal 3 and they
said no i agree with you
but you got to pass me because i'm you
know i'm
i'm making some decisions in my life and
this is really the last class i need to
graduate he said well you know you're
just you're just not me making the
standard i said and then you intimidated
him with your muscles
no on the contrary what i told him is
that i i said listen i don't like being
any here any more than you want me being
here and i'll make you a promise
if you fail me again i promise you i
will continue to be here and take your
class
every single day
every single day until you retire
oh wow
and he looked at his commitment and he
said
so i guess we have a mutual
understanding that
you're just gonna barely pass
and i said sir that's all i need i i'm
not looking for an a i just need to pass
this class and i'll be out of your hair
forever
and he said
okay
we have an agreement then
and that is i i i just barely passed
that class and um
yeah it's either count two or count
three and um we made an agreement he uh
uh i i wouldn't take calculus anymore
for the rest of my life and um you know
there you have it that number that was
less than zero or could be less than
zero do you happen to remember if it was
mass
uh i had no idea brother i i know who
who gave it to me i don't want to
reveal that person right now let's
forget about that you know honestly by
the time they got through the whole that
my eyes had rolled in the back of my
head about three times um
and um they were obviously very excited
about as i was writing these formulas
down and said bam there's the answer i'm
like huh
where
see for me math is what turns me on
i love it no don't get me wrong i wish i
wish
i i i absolutely love math it's it's
just doing it that for me is kind of
kind of challenging um
okay so alien alcoholic asks
potentially have there been biological
samples recovered from craft
let's rephrase that question have there
potentially been biological samples
recovered
yes
i'm not going to expand it right right
so let's forget about the craft
and and be careful when i say that i'm
being purposely very open and vague at
the same time right
what does that mean
well it means what it means
senzu bean
has he ever considered that when the uap
changes direction or speed it may
actually be warping space time
like the
like certain warp drives i'm sure you've
heard of
that way the space time around the uap
is warped and so it's not technically
moving
and thus the biological entities if
there are one or any wouldn't feel
g-forces have you considered that
essentially is what senzu bean is yeah
it's right on the money except for
except except for it is moving but it's
but that the principles of what that
question is are right on the money
yes
and then i just wanted to say it i
always love when people say this at the
end hopefully my question makes sense as
i'm not a native english speaker kind
regards hey man your question makes
complete sense you know what he speaks
better english or she speaks better
english than most most english speakers
so congratulations i understood the
question perfectly and and it's a great
question and yeah
okay so this question comes from steve
cambion of truth seekers and i'll put a
link to his podcast in the description
given the debate about your involvement
with atip and your actual role
would you be able to prove your
leadership role by releasing tax forms
tax forms in short could you simply
release your tax form tax forms to prove
your employment leadership role and your
salary for those years
of course i could but tax forms just
tell you you're working at a particular
office that's all it does
um and of course then you know you you
start
people start
looking at your your salaries and start
you know making all sorts of inferences
the bottom line is that the government
has already validated and verified that
i work uh within the usdi
um the senator reid has already
validated work on on atip
you had the spokesperson for the
pentagon dana white under um under the
secretary
mattis already verify that i was working
a tip you have jim likowski verifying i
worked in rana atip you have i mean if
the list goes on and on and on and on no
i'm not going to get into a tip for chad
you know if you
don't want i mean that on the world's
greatest clairvoyant because everything
i've talked about has come to fruition
to include the release of the videos
that are on the 1910 with my signature
both are remarkable
i mean at this point if if people still
question that then you know i i don't
know what to tell you um you know
go get a hobby you know no i'm not i'm
not going to sit here at this point in
time
uh you know there's an ig evaluation and
investigation specifically because of of
how they mishandled this and then they
come out and they say oh by the way we
deleted all those emails i mean if
you're that much of a sucker and you
actually you know still at this point
are are at all questioning what my role
is then
you know i'll tell you
sorry
okay this question comes from ina etter
question for lou what can we do
personally to prepare ourselves
and perhaps even
post disclosure world
are we taking a break you need to no no
actually i was trying to find an email
that uh that
never mind i had an email that i've
never shown but i was about to say here
boom how's that for proof but no don't
worry about it i don't want to get into
that it's it's you know what
we'll talk about that potentially i'm
not going to satisfy anybody's at this
point questioning you know it's all that
is is and by the way as time goes on
even more evidence is coming so you know
you find it to be a distraction and a
waste of time we have much greater
issues well and at this point it's just
insulting it's like dude i can't think
for you at this point i mean if at this
point you're still on the fence on that
then you know
find something else to do because it's
yeah it's it
it would be like seeing obama's birth
certificate and then saying that he's
still from kenya he'd be like what more
do you want from me yeah it's like dude
what more do you want you have the guy
who ran the program the senator himself
saying i ran it i mean you had the
pentagon say now you have 60 minutes who
by the way backed it up with general
mattis himself i'm like
what more you want i mean
you want a video of me going in out of
the office when i was there well you're
not going to get that you know sorry
um
you know unfortunately there's a lot of
people out there that are still
i i consider agent provocateurs they're
just trying to
to confuse the situation and for
whatever reason you know i mean
rather than looking at the last four
years and say wow look how far we've
come
you know they rather go back and and you
know it's
have you heard of anjali
i have
okay see people keep telling me to look
her up and then many other people keep
saying don't bother she's way out there
which also makes me want to look her up
even further
and i think i've been on some polls and
you've been on some polls as
who should
she take with her as a representative or
as one of several representatives for
the planet earth well i never said i'd
go with her first of all so i don't know
why someone's using my name
you know in a poll without my permission
saying that you know they'll take me
anywhere you know
no one's taking me anywhere unless i
want to go somewhere
two um
you know the old saying extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence
you know nothing would make me happier
if she can you know take somebody to a
magic cave underground and have
communication with a
with another life form um but
if that's the case and what are you
waiting for why not go now just bring a
camera crew go now you don't need to
make a big deal of this um just go and
do it and prove it you know at this
we've seen this in the community so many
times before with people
making these bold claims and you know
man i really hope i'm wrong i'd love to
eat my hat you know i'll be the first
one there's an old saying we have you
know if if i'm wrong i will kiss her
butt in front of me she's window um i i
nothing would make me happier than that
uh than to to that to be true but
everything about how this is unfolding
doesn't seem doesn't seem legit to me um
it seems
showboat you know when you have someone
sitting on a chair with
well anyways i don't look i don't want
to be judgmental enough people are
judgmental about me i know how it feels
you know i want i want to give angelie a
fair shake but
but you better produce because if you
don't you got a lot of people riding on
this and all you're going to do is hurt
the cause you know with some outlandish
claim like this if you can't prove this
outlandish claim
all you are going to be responsible for
is being another one of those people
that are that are tin foil hat and the
reason why this topic was never taken
seriously so add yourself to the list if
you can't if you can't deliver
when i looked at her and i didn't look
at her much i just saw a couple videos i
didn't sense any dishonesty but i didn't
have a
i didn't have anything like a close
gander let's say
so you sense some grandstanding or
showboating
no no look i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
judge anybody i'm not i'm not i'm just
simply saying that you know if you've
got
extraordinary claims like that you've
got to deliver you've got a
responsibility now and and you better
not have an excuse not to deliver that
all right so this question comes from
aina etter i believe that's how you
pronounce this person's name what can we
do personally and even societally to
prepare ourselves and others for a post
post-disclosure world
i'm not sure we need to prepare it all i
think we're perfectly prepared i i have
faith in
in human beings that we will look at
this from a rational perspective you
know we are our paradigm is challenged
every day we just had uh
in the media um
you know
china launched a hypersonic cruise
missile around the world
um
you know that's that's a change in the
way we we we we see ourselves
especially with with potential foreign
adversaries
we have our paradigms change every day
people are told that they have cancer
every day
people are told that spouses are
cheating on them every day people are
told that they're pregnant and are going
to have kids every day
people are told about the death of a
loved one every day
we're human beings that's part of life
i think
i'm not sure there's anything we can do
to prepare um i think just just be
ourselves and be willing to ask the the
hard questions
and and uh have the patience to to to
find the answers you know let's not be
so quick to to jump into some sort of
preconceived narrative just because it
makes us feel good right because we all
want we all want to understand things
that we don't we all have this natural
fear of things we can't understand
we must be tempted not to create an
artificial narrative
just so we feel better we need to really
explore this for what it is and and
have the courage to do so um
that would be my advice
okay i need to urinate do you need to
use the washroom uh i will if if you
have time yes i don't know how you're
let's just get going
i'll you sure put yeah i'll turn this
off and turn off the audio well i'll
keep mine on not that i plan on
necessarily going here but i actually
have a
bathroom that people may like that
be right back folks thanks all right
okay for those who are in the chat
don't worry if you've super chatted and
i didn't get
to your question because i'll read them
all at the end and i will also
prioritize them for the next time when i
speak with lou provided he's generous
enough to speak with me again
two hours later
all right kurt i'm gonna give you some
some some hell here i know you didn't
have time to go to the bathroom and wash
your hands and that
[Laughter]
okay
i'm extremely quick
i i you put me on the spot man at least
i should be able to put you on the spot
a little bit too
all right
okay let's see
by the way these are some really good
questions i really appreciate yeah yeah
well this is questions that people
haven't asked me before yeah man really
good by the way let me also caveat here
you're gonna get i do have some people
that really don't like me and i'm sure
they're gonna take out that
uh that hatred on you so i apologize
ahead of time if anybody is
screaming at you i got some i got some
some haters in my camp um that uh tend
to be rather vocal so i i i hope they're
not driving you too crazy no i've got uh
a nice little vocal i almost can i
probably call them
my chorus because uh i know every time i
come out and say anything like on this
show uh that course is gonna come out
any minute now and uh i can i can
already hear them uh you know warming up
their
voices
the last time we spoke there were two
comments that you said that stood out to
me well one was the somber the somber
heard around the world in a sense
and then you clarified that or you added
to that by saying sobering oh i was
wondering we can get to that and then
also you mentioned that the charlatans
of the world will
be shown to be charlatans and i again
don't know much about this ufo community
but people in the comments were saying
did he mean stephen greer
so why don't you comment on that
you can be as diplomatic as you like i
know that you're you're a relatively
diplomatic person yeah let me um
let me start with by by somber sobering
um
imagine
imagine everything you've been taught
whether it's through sunday school or
through
regular formal education in school or
what our political leaders have told us
and yes even maybe our mothers and
fathers around the dinner table have
told us or maybe at bedtime um about
about who we are
right in our background in our past um
what if
all of that turned out to be
not entirely accurate
in fact
the very history of of our species
the meaning what it means to be a human
being and our place in this universe
what if all that is now
in question
what if it turns out that a lot of the
things that we
thought were one way
aren't
are
are we prepared
to have that honest question with
ourselves
are we prepared to
to recognize that we're not at the top
of the food chain potentially
that we're not the alpha predator that
we are
um
maybe somewhere in the middle
um
you know it's it's interesting because
i was having discussion with a friend uh
not too long ago really really we call
them graybeards in the in in the
government really really smart guy i'm
not going to mention his name but but i
was talking to him probably a couple
months ago
and this is a guy who was always paid to
solve the hard problems for the us
government cold war how do we solve that
right how do we do these big big things
how do we go in and
and uh and beat the russians at their
own game um
so this guy i respect tremendously and
and we had a conversation he said you
know lou um
mankind's been around for a little while
and for most of that time mankind's been
around we've been smack in the middle of
the food chain we've been
um you know we we ate a lot of things a
lot of things ate us and that's just the
bottom line
and about 70 000 years ago something
fundamentally changed
something changed and and our species
was instantly catapulted to the very top
of our planet as far as predatory
animals
and um
and now all of a sudden
we became the most feared
um we we we were the most lethal
and the most successful in fact
uh most of the large species that that
that existed on this planet went extinct
because of us believe it or not because
we we
eating all of it
there were a couple species that did
very very well with our ascension our
immediate ascension and we brought a
couple species with us the dog as an
example where the dog species benefited
greatly with mankind's ascension as the
alpha predator and and wanda succeeding
as well very doing very well off of that
that changed the the entire global
landscape of our planet
um almost overnight large animals went
extinct
because of us
what if it turns out that
there's another species
that
is is even even
even higher on on that on that ladder
than we are
um
[Music]
do we need the social institutions
that we have today will we need
governmental and religious organizations
that we have today
if it turns out that
um there is something else or someone
else
um
that is that is uh technologically more
advanced
and and perhaps from an evolutionary
perspective more advanced
um
have we been wasting our time all this
time
or
are we doing exactly what we're supposed
to be doing
um
are we or are we does it turn out that
mankind is is in fact
just another animal in the zoo
or because we thought ourselves as a
zookeeper before but maybe we're just
another exhibit inside the zoo
what would that mean to us so so when i
say sombering and sobering
uh i mean that it's it you know
there's gonna come a point in this
conversation we're gonna have to do a
lot of reconciling with ourselves
whatever that means from whatever
philosophical background you
you have
this is going to impact every single one
of us the same and yet equally and it
differently
and i think that's important
know
do we find ourselves in a situation
where history may have to be rewritten
um
so that's what i meant now as far as the
charlatans i'm not going to give any
attention to individual charlatans
because they already have enough
attention they know exactly who i am
referring to
these are individuals who have have have
made a a cottage industry a career of
taking people's hard-earned money and
deceiving them and not only deceiving
them but having them sign
non-disclosure agreements to make sure
they don't tell the world that they've
been deceived
and preying upon people who
who for whatever reason
believe in them
people who say
my narrative is the only narrative and
anybody else who tells you otherwise
you know is trying to hurt you
i have all the answers i have the
solution
anybody who says that i think um
i think it's a charlatan
and and i think we need to be very very
mindful of that they're very dangerous
uh and they're dangerous for several
reasons because if they're lying to you
about that they're probably lying to you
about other things in their life their
past life and their current life
uh which may or may not come to light at
some point um these are people who
who have taken advantage of people for a
very long time
and uh
you know you you have to be careful
you know
what else are the motivations of some of
these charlatans or potentially could be
their motivation other than financial
look at any religious charlatans it's
the same thing it's a cult it's a cult
of personality it's somebody
who for whatever reason thinks it's all
about them
and and they manage the narrative it's
it's it goes to the to the basic core of
pride and ego in human beings
um and narcissistic behavior
you know real true deep psychological
issues um some sociopathic to be honest
with you
um
is there any gold in that rubble
i'm sorry is there any gold in that
rubble as in is all of what they're
saying some of these charlatans we don't
have to name names i no i think i think
i think there's always there's always
fibers of truth
in in in a blanket of lies
um because that's that's what holds it
together there are some there are some
aspects of truth the problem is um when
you take that truth and and you distort
it
you know
there's people in history that that
we're very good at convincing large
amounts of people that they have the
answer right um i don't need to go back
into into history to say which ones
those are but you have
characters like jim jones
heaven's gate as an example
you know even hitler to some degree
where where
they were
very charismatic people
who who got people in in this this web
and they didn't realize it until it was
too late
and um
you know i i just think when you when
you're creating all these shell
organizations and pass-throughs and
paying people off to do things for you
to deceive other people i think is
problematic again i'm not going to say
i'm not going to mention names i i i
think most people are smart enough to
see through it
my concern are those people who who are
already already
sucked into it it becomes a cult and
becomes brainwashing and manipulation
and that's my concern because it gives a
terrible name to the to the to the
effort
and and making false accusations
um you know i i think is is
there's an old saying and see if i can
remember it that um
ye be careful of the knife
ye uses to stab stabilize the back of
others
for surely that knife will be used
against you in the future or at some
point so you know um
anyway being just you know
right karma karma is a [ __ ]
be careful
you know mother nature has a vote she's
got a way of always uh squaring things
up at the end and um you know that's
that's what i've seen anyways
remember earlier i was asking what can
we do as a culture i think
based on some of your statements
what we can do is
something like we've already been doing
which is keep talking about it so that
we can de-stigmatize it i know that
i don't particularly like the word
destigmatization i think it's been
taken by certain people but essentially
to de-stigmatize however
there does seem to be the tendency from
those who are believers in
or who are part of the ufo community who
deride people like
see neil degrasse tyson and other
skeptics deride the ufo community
and i don't think
they should do that but then i also
don't think that
they should be met with condescension as
well because i think that that comes
back at you i think that love and
extending an arm and an olive branch
is what will
kurt you're right you're absolutely
right let me let me if i may yes that's
a good point let me talk a little bit
about uh mr neil degrasse tyson first of
all i i he's one of the few shows that i
used to watch a lot um i loved his
perspective
and let's talk about his background you
know this is a person who was a bit of a
maverick he he cut his teeth and became
really made his bones by
by
by supporting and defending a theory
that really was a hypothesis at the time
an outlandish hypothesis and that was
there were these supermassive objects
in our universe that were so dense that
they created a gravity well they created
a black hole in space-time where light
itself couldn't even escape and although
we can't see it
uh directly we can't prove its existence
we think they're there right now a lot
of the scientific community said it's
hogwash you know it's it's just
it's a theoretical anomaly that that
isn't real
and yet neil degrassi tyson did exactly
that he he supported
the hypothesis and theory that there are
these
things you'll never be able to see with
the naked eye but they fundamentally
they're there
and they're hundreds of millions of
light years away
well it's funny because that same spirit
used to to prove something you can never
see
that is there
for some reason he seems to have
forgotten that in this topic
because we're talking about the same
thing we're talking about something
that is hard to see directly sometimes
but we can we can see its impact on on
the environment around it
uh and to some degree maybe you know
warping space time and but
it's not hundreds of millions of miles
away it's right here
and and i don't understand how you can
support in one hand
the
the
the scientific study and research into
something called a black hole
and not be open-minded to to something
like uap it to me that
it's um
it's the same thought process
now um going back to what you say as far
as ridiculing them
no we shouldn't ridicule them
well what we need to do is help them see
the
the contradiction in their argument
and not in a mean spiteful way either
um you know i
i think we need to have a conversation
because we need people like neil
degrassi tyson we need
people to to to who are very smart to
look at this problem and not just reject
it because of of
of stigma taboo but the problem with the
scientific community today is that
they've rejected science instead favor
of scientism and scientism is no
different than any other religion
it's where you are so married to the
scientific methodologies that you no
longer can accept new hypothesis
and theories
um and you reject them flatly and i
think that's problematic because as i've
said before every single
principle of science today
whether it's a a theory or a law of
science that we accept as just normal
part of everyday life and science
started off as someone's wacky zany idea
way back when
everything and so
i don't understand how we continue to
find ourselves in the same hole every
time we keep saying well now they've
been
that's impossible but
damn it every time you say that you we
get proven wrong why
haven't you learned your lesson you know
haven't you taken your notes from
from from the u.s patent office when
when they said that
bold claim that you know now
now everything in the world has been
invented in a few years right right for
a u.s patent office anymore i mean how
short-sighted can you possibly be that's
that's the antithesis
of scientific pursuit and endeavor
and i think you know if you were to ask
me
my true feelings on this which again i
don't offer very often
science and religion
when you are standing at their base they
could not be any farther apart think of
a pyramid going to the great pyramid of
giza and standing on one side of the
pyramid say this is science
and then walking around all the way to
the side of the pyramid and say this is
faith this is religion and the two could
not be further apart from each other and
yet
when you start to climb that period
on which other side you go on
they start to get closer and closer
together in fact at some point
at the very top
the difference between science and
religion
are indistinguishable
they are they are not mutually exclusive
in fact
they they
they are together they're one they're
one and the same and in fact
i think part of the problem is that in
science and in faith we're asking two
fundamental different questions this is
why the two don't get along uh down at
the base of the pyramid this why they
seem so opposite because one is asking
how
and the other is asking why
and they're two different questions and
that's why the two
don't seem to be
don't seem to comport with one another
but ironically enough the further you go
up the ladder the more you realize
they actually require each other they
actually lean on each other they
actually support each other and and at
the very top there's there's no
difference between science and and
and religion they they they become one
and they support each other i think
anyways that's that's my perspective
from what i've seen in life
you know you mentioned a phrase it's a
phrase i don't particularly like it's
that i say a lot of things that people
don't like so i i apologize curt ahead
of time
i apologize if i'm about to offend you
it's extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence the reason i
don't like that
is because people like neil degrasse
tyson any skeptic will say that any
claim that
they've already deemed as being untrue
and even dr brian keating who is a
he's a friend and he almost won the
nobel prize he's an experimentalist
physicist
he said i don't ask my graduate students
go find the extraordinary evidence it's
not a different class of evidence that's
called extraordinary
also what's the extraordinary evidence
that any of us are conscious there's
actually zero evidence that you can
point to scientifically outside of what
people say
and then well what are you going to take
what people say well you could just ask
a computer are you conscious and so on
so on so that's why i don't particularly
like that yeah i think you're well i i
don't disagree with you i i think that's
a really good point um i think i was
taking it more in the vernacular right
so if you're going to say something has
been
substantiated by observation over and
over again multiple times to
substantiate
x equals three right and now you're
going to come out and say no actually x
equals four
then you are going to need evidence that
is beyond what it currently
is available to prove that because all
the evidence right now is suggesting x
equals three and yet now you are
claiming x equals four well that is a
it is by definition extra ordinary the
ordinary claim being x equals 3 right in
simple algebra
but now you're making an extra or beyond
ordinary claim that x does not equal 3
equals 4. so therefore you're going to
need beyond ordinary evidence beyond
what showing x equals three to prove now
your theory that x equals four and so
from my perspective when i say
extraordinary you know uh claims
requires extraordinary evidence i don't
necessarily mean um
perhaps the way a lot of people mean i
just mean it's beyond just like the word
normal versus paranormal it is by
definition extraordinary
extraordinary
but i see your point and i think you're
right i think i think part of the
problem is that we we get too
comfortable in in in the current
understanding of of uh
of our current paradigm and we're not
willing to challenge
uh was with sometimes very simple things
you know um case in point is i just had
this conversation not too long ago
publicly about fractals
you know they've been in front of us all
along ever since we were living in caves
and yet it's only recently realized that
that may be part of the secret to the
universe right that fractals exist
everywhere uh they they agree they exist
physically they
exist uh
from a uh from a even a psychological
perspective the way we we we relate to
one another um
and and it's been in front of us all
it's obvious it's you know it's not
really extraordinary at all it's it's
actually blatantly obvious and we just
never saw it um so yeah that's a good
point i think you're right and and maybe
i need to rephrase that in the future
um i'll consider that because i think
you may be right maybe maybe maybe
that's not an entirely good way to go
about it you know extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence maybe
maybe we're beyond that in a
conversation
so great thanks for sharing that with me
and no by the way you did not insult me
at all okay yeah i appreciate that a lot
thanks man
reuter router or however you pronounce
this i'll leave the name in the
description it says great show can you
ask lou the following based upon what
you've learned lou would you consider
yourself to be an idealist or a
materialist and if you are unsure what
those words mean no no no
um is there an option c
which would be what mix can it be both
or neither um that's something i've been
wondering is there a duality between
those two there's plenty of dualities in
math and physics where you think
it's the option between two but turns
out that they're equivalent ways of
describing a system yeah exactly i'm not
sure it's uh either or i'm not sure
they're mutually exclusive i think you
know i i
my background was science um
you know in in in science i found my
solace which i enjoyed um
you know i i grew up kind of a kind of a
angry young kid had some some tough
times as a kid
but but science to me was
it was unwavering
she was always there for me she never
lied to me and so
uh
i i get lost in science
and um
you know i i i
i do believe in the scientific method um
it works it's it's i mean it's a perfect
no but it's the best thing that we got
right now that we know
uh to test and apply theories um
but at the same time you know there's
something more you said about human
consciousness you know can't prove it
there's no mathematical formula no
physical evidence to prove consciousness
and here we are having a conversation so
um
i think i don't think
i don't think the two are mutually i
don't consider myself a materialist or
an idealist um like i said it's you know
like when i make fun of the fact that i
you know i said i love humanity it's
humans i don't like right um
how is that possible right because
humanity's a collective of all the
humans and yet uh but um
probably a little bit of both
probably i think there's an indelible
aspect to the human being that is um
that transcends physicality um you know
we have a body obviously
and we have a brain
and our brain is inextricably tied for
metabolic processes to survive to the
body the heart has to pump blood to get
blood to the brain otherwise the brain
dies and in the same respect the brain
is regulating all the autonomic
processes for the body so you know
breathing which is automatic thank god
for most of us anyways
uh and uh and heartbeat and temperature
and whatnot so the the brain
is a biological organ uh organ that is
inextricably tied to the overall vehicle
which is the body and that's organic as
well
but there's probably something more to
the human being
there's probably something more that is
not necessarily physical
because a computer has a processor the
computer has a body right the laptop i'm
talking to you on right now and it's got
a processor that's thinking if you will
for the computer but it's not a
conscious living being it's not a
sentient being
so the question is what is that extra
component that extra ingredient
that
makes us human that makes us a living
breathing not only animal
but truly human what separates us from
everything else on this planet
and there's that third ingredient can be
described potentially in in cultures as
the soul or the id or the chi or what
you know but you're nom de jour you want
on there
but i think a lot of people agree that
there's something different um
case in point the the the notion of love
um
you can't really describe it it's hard
to describe you can't see it you can't
touch it and taste it
but it's there and it motivates a lot of
people's
actions in fact love to some degree
actually works against individual
survival and yet a mother's instinct to
throw herself in front of a train to
save her child
is almost reflexive
um you know there's something there that
recognizes the value of human life human
dignity um i could be in a car accident
and and lose use of my arms and my legs
but i'm still lou elizondo
um i could suffer a traumatic brain
injury and and
have a severe tbi
and be mentally impaired but i'm still
lou elizondo
what makes lou elizondo lou is
is something a little bit different
something that you can't really put your
finger on and so
back to this duality you know
materialist versus you know idealist
i'm probably a little bit of both
because i believe in science but i also
know that there's limitations to science
and there's limitations to human beings
and there's limitations to you and me
and everybody else and that's okay
and that that
there's aspects to to being human
that are probably potentially more human
than human to use an old cliche so
um
great question if i if i can ask you
kurt question i never asked you just
take a break here for a minute and ask
you
what got you into this why why why did
you want to
get into this topic and have this
conversation with your background um
i
i mean i
i suspect you have your reasons but
i'd love to know why
originally
i was what people would categorize as an
adamant atheist and that was recently
too just a few years ago and i'm not
saying i'm a theist now but i'm not an
atheist
and just so you know some atheists will
say they don't believe in god because
well the concept of god is volutinous
and amorphous how do you pin it down
well then technically you can't say
you're an atheist because you can't be
anti-what's cloud-like yourself
you can't be against nothing
so
so either way i was speaking with
someone who told me you know aliens
exist and i gave him my standard spiel
which is well why do they look like us
it's two humans it came out
the the reports of aliens spike every
time there's a movie so it seems
culturally relate the standard skeptic
response yeah anthropomorphism etc yeah
right and also look given our
exponential curve for technological
progress why do these craft seem all
alike now of course they're very they're
varied in terms of shape and size but
still they're recognizable as craft and
if you're let's say you're coming from a
planet far away then even if you were to
travel there
time has you can travel there instance
almost instantaneously but thousands of
years may have passed and so then your
technology would have increased so i had
the standard
skeptical response and then he said kurt
just watch this just why he sent me a
few videos and i watched them and then i
was
i think i've said this before if i have
any skill it's not math or physics it's
body language i watch people's body
language like a hawk
and i can tell when they're insecure
about a certain aspect of what they're
saying when they don't feel intelligent
enough when they feel intimidated when
they feel like they have to
well
you can continue on the list and i
didn't see deception in what i saw
and so that got me interested and i
decided to speak to jeremy corbell
because i was a filmmaker i still
categorized myself as that and he was
one and still is so i was like okay let
me speak to jeremy he has a movie on bob
lazar and since then well i've been
interested in it because of the physics
but i'm also interested in the deep
mysteries of the world
and it seems like
it seems like ufos tie in to them and if
even if they don't it's still incredibly
informing
so that's my
interest in it and luckily or unluckily
i don't have a
scornful despising mind like most of the
scientific community
i i don't
look upon the subject with ridicule
and in fact i i don't particularly like
when people ridicule other people
i think it
i think that's an indication they should
examine themselves for what they're
holding to be a self-evident truth
and
question their own motivations for
believing in it because if there's an
emotion attached to it then there's some
unconscious motivation for holding that
belief that isn't purely a dispassionate
assessment
of the evidence
so that's my
reason very well said let me let me ask
you a further question if i made that
not that i'm interviewing you but sure
this this is it's actually a question
for your audience too but but i can't
talk to your whole audience other than
addressing you so i'll address you
um
you know we look in terms of everything
from a humanistic perspective and we
want to make sense from nonsense it's
just kind of
in our dna right um
when we are talking about the topic of
uap
i think everybody deep down inside has
this innate desire for it to quote make
sense
put it in a neat little box
and it makes sense to us
the problem is the more we talk about
uaps the more we exchange ideas and then
the more we begin to formulate our own
opinions about uaps and so what happens
when
the topic of uap the truth doesn't
comport
because we're all doing this
right now subconsciously
subconsciously every person does it you
are we are creating these little
boxes that we want to check off
regarding this topic of it's from outer
space it's from inner dimension it's
this and they want this and they can do
that and they can do it today
that's what you're saying
and we are building those boxes without
even realizing it so when we ask the
questions we're actually asking the
questions in a way
to fill those to check those boxes that
we've already made up psychologically in
our brain and our subconscious right
but we have to avoid doing that
and it it's so natural that we don't
even realize we're doing it how do we
avoid the temptation
to ask really the big question
[Music]
without without being tempted to fill in
the little box you know a lot of the
questions your your wonderful audience
has asked
may not even realize but they're trying
to fill check those boxes that they've
made for themselves and their brain
they've they've preconceived these
little boxes that they must have an
answer to this box
because this box then relates to this
and this and this this gives me a bigger
overall picture and answer that i'm
looking for but
but what if this is even far more
bizarre than that
that how do we
how do we ask a question
[Music]
to something we don't even know what
questions to ask meaning maybe maybe
we're asking maybe maybe it's not even
in the realm of our ability to really
get to the root of this because we're
looking at everything from a human
perspective human motivation human
interest
human desire
fears
um
you know what if it's something
completely different and and
so in essence we need to avoid creating
these little boxes prematurely in our
mind
um which is hard because we're that's
what we do as a species and everything
that we do right you know
uh take dating for example when you go
on a date with somebody what's the first
thing you do say well do i like them are
we compatible do we like the same things
do we like to eat the same the same
dietary you know
am i vegan they're a meat eater you know
these little boxes that we put in our
brain you know um already before you've
even asked a question we have these
these little voids up you want to fill
and and the question is how do we how do
we avoid that temptation
how do we how do we
pull ourselves out of a human
paradigm
to ask the questions that maybe
aren't human questions at all i don't
know so i just offer that up to you
because
that's a great point
there's a term for that it's called
enthe memes have you heard of that
no no please explain people in the
audience it's just an unstated
assumption you don't realize you're
making it when you're asking a question
or putting forward a statement
so for example let's imagine worms they
see humans and they just conceive of
humans as god-like then they would ask
well they must eat the best dirt what
dirt do they eat they don't realize
they're asking the wrong question
exactly precisely what my point is so do
you what do you call it emphamine n-the
meme so
n t h e-n-e-n-t-h-y m e m e if you want
a fun physics one which i could say in
like 20 seconds
ed whitton so one of the world's
greatest physicist said there's no such
you can't no go theorem so you can't
have a particle that
has that that is massless and has
greater than half spin and also carry a
charge that's lauren's covariant which
means follows einstein's equations
okay
which
seems like it means there's no such
particle as a graviton because graviton
has mass sorry has spin 2 and is
massless
okay
however this unstated assumption that
you don't realize and even edwin didn't
realize he was making it was that the
graviton is in the same space time and
so this is one of the reasons that
there's this ads cft correspondence
where you have holography you've heard
of the holographic yeah absolutely sure
sure because it seems like well there's
a correspondence between cft so
conformal field theory
and then having gravity on the boundary
of that or vice versa so the bound so
gravity could be somewhere else and
there's a correspondence between those
correct correct correct but it's
actually extremely tricky to extract
that from the statement that you can't
have a particle that is of greater than
spin half and massless and so on and so
on it's it's difficult to see the
assumption that in that statement
so that's what an enthymeme is yeah
yeah that's fantastic yeah that's uh i
appreciate that thank you kurt for
sharing that that's that
that if anything that was worth totally
me
being here i really appreciate that i'm
just i i feel so relaxed with you and
i'm so i'm so honored that
you're spending some time with me man
well it's it's collected right i mean
you got a great audience you're asking
great questions and and i feel that you
know i almost feel like this is like a
fireside chat if we could all just be
sitting together out here in wyoming you
know and evening around a fire this is
exactly what i'd be spending my time
doing um yeah you know this is this is i
wish i could do this more often um i
really do unfortunately you know much of
my
my time is uh is committed to to other
endeavors within this effort but um i
think this is important because
ultimately
[Music]
look we're going to solve this mystery
together all of us and this isn't going
to be up to lou it's not going to be up
to kurt it's not going to be up to you
know
greer
or anybody else uh it's it's
it's up to to all of us um and uh
you know that old that old uh that old
saying what was it i saw it recently
somebody couple things i saw one really
neat on the internet um you know with
with somebody who was being angry and
someone said
come let us share smoke at the fire you
know by the fire i've sold a
kind of an indigenous you know uh
proverb right saying hey let's let's
let's share smoke at the fire let's
let's put our let's stop grinding the
axes let's let's put our differences
aside let's
let's let's come together
i like that another thing too by the way
i don't know who does it it's completely
off topic and random but i'm going to
since i got a little bit of time here
i'm going to say it anyways
there is an artist
that has been drawing me and i gotta
tell you i don't know if he likes me or
hates me but man it is amazing artwork
man this this this person has somehow
managed to capture
it's kind of like a comic book style um
and usually draws me with tiny little
beady eyes i don't know i don't know i
you know i i i've seen it a few times um
you know it's uh it it's it i don't know
if it's like a japanese anime style
really
yeah and uh again i don't know they if
they're if they hate me or or they love
me or indifferent i'm pretty sure it's
it's a positive feeling they wouldn't
man i gotta tell you really really
talented artists man i actually screen
grabbed a couple of those and just saved
them and showed my wife i said man
look at this this is really clever you
know um
one of them is uh it's i guess
jokingly you know all the work i've done
in the government and all of a sudden
now i'm being assigned a ufo program and
there's this kind of you know reaction
which actually wasn't
too far from the truth
uh but just really really talented so
big shout out to whoever whoever you are
out there um you know again whether
you're you're a fan or a hater know that
uh know that i'm your fan either way so
so
you're very very talented if you find
the person's name or
person if you
are watching this just leave some
comments and i'll put your link in the
description as well okay i gotta get to
some more super chat and audience
questions they're eager
do-it-yourself craft q asks what's his
take on alien abduction experience
they're interesting they're fascinating
but
they're just that they're an experience
um and with every person who
who talks about uh you know how how
these things may be here for peaceful
purposes and you know just because
they've never
uh attacked us means that they're
they're benevolent there's just as many
people who are terrified and and report
the opposite experience um
you know i said this before for record
look if you take
a member of my family against their will
somewhere that's kidnapping
uh and god forbid if you touch him now
that's assault you know both are
criminal um
offenses um from my perspective i don't
care what your intent is bottom line so
i if abductions are happening um well
the award of abduction itself is a
criminal act right it's kidnapping
um
it's not taking you on a date it's
abduction um if that indeed is happening
the problem is it's very hard to
quantify and qualify
um
that that aspect of the conversation
because at the end of the day you're
just relying on eyewitness testimony
there's no gun camera footage there's no
radar data to suggest that it's just
someone's
personal experience
and when you do that
you have to consider all sorts of stuff
you know
you have to
you're now talking about aspects that
involve psychology uh aspects that are
called aspects that involve sociology
and aspects that
involve philosophy
you know we all interpret data
differently
as human beings
processes occur differently in our
brains and biochemically even
so it's very hard
to
to
do anything with that data from a
military perspective from a dod
perspective because
you know eyewitness testimony is one
thing and even that's tricky sometimes
but when you start talking about
experiences physical experiences from
people and and they vary so much in some
cases in some cases they're similar
there's not a whole lot i can do with
that data
so
although it's extremely interesting
fascinating in fact
um
it was never really a core part of our
our research in a tip um again because
scientifically it's very hard to
quantify and qualify and there's there's
nobody else that can that can say yes i
saw this person there's a few small
anecdotal examples here and there where
people say i saw the person disappear or
something like that but
that doesn't help us we need we need
more information or more data you know
um i will tell you
no actually no wait
sorry next time
yeah next time yeah uh there there it
it's it's interesting someone asked
about why is it that we have cattle
mutilations predominantly
we don't hear much about sheep
and chicken and so on is there
oh yeah okay so this is a hickle that's
right hicko asks why is it
not on other livestock well i'm sure
there's a minor amount why is it
predominantly on cattle or at least
predominantly we hear about it on cattle
yeah we don't know why um it could be
something as simple as just you know the
bovine genetic sequencing it could be
the fact that
you can put a genetic tracer in an
animal
and and follow the the natural mutations
of the genetic sequencing uh the
genotype and phenotype uh manifestations
over time
you know if i were to let's say in the
1950s put a marker specific marker in in
in a specific uh herd of cow
uh or head of cattle and then the cattle
and then then watch as that that genetic
marker changes over time um you know
there's all sorts of things you can you
can find it could also be that certain
animals are like canaries in a in a mine
they're just they seem to be more
sensitive to whatever reason to to
environmental changes or something to
that effect and so you know that is the
animal of choice
um
you know we don't really know
and and there's still a lot of debate on
what
what that is of what catalans are some
will speculate that it's uh it's uh you
know uap related some will speculate
that no it's some sort of secret
government program to to
uh for for tracking biological weapons
testing others upon that it's something
completely unrelated it's natural it's
caused by coyotes and you know
natural attrition of the of the
of the herd um we don't really know but
but assuming let's just assume for a
moment everybody say a word let's see
let's presume because you know what
assuming does right
so let's we'll presume here instead of
assume
um let's just presume that it does have
some sort of relationship to uap for
example what
why would we why would we why would
anybody why would anything be interested
in one particular species
there's all sorts of reasons why
it could be that there is a special
susceptibility to certain things
um again that going back to the canary
analogy right that for whatever reason
it's also could be that they're widely
available that there's you know i'm
living here in wyoming there's more head
of cattle here in wyoming than our
people that's a true statement we have
more cows and we have people that's one
hypothesis i was thinking about have you
heard of mccready explosion
it's that the if you look at the amount
so end of any animal by mass which one
is the most plentiful on the planet it's
not humans it's actually cattle or right
cattle is second to humans so i'm
wondering how much of it is just because
there's so many of them that well
there's a lot of numbers and and it's
huge numbers and they're all over
all over the world uh and they're also a
lot of them are really really remote you
know so if you wanted to get in and get
out and do something
you know kyle's pretty easy target you
know cheetahs run really fast right and
then
alligators those are great points yeah
okay so before i rudely interrupted you
you're saying there was
the reason of being plentiful of being
perhaps susceptible like a canary in the
coal mine and then you're going on what
was the next yeah uh it could also be
that you know they have been so cows are
are one of the few species that have
been specifically manipulated by human
beings um you know there was a time
where where our species hunted something
called an aurochs and the orox was was
predominant all over the planet and we
hunted them frankly to extinction um
what you see now in the domesticated
cattle is really really
a crossbreed
it was it was made by it was invented by
humans
it's kind of the animal that never was
to some degree we've crossbred a lot of
stuff so we now have this domesticated
livestock that we used as a food source
maybe there's something in that maybe
there's there's there's something
significant or specific as it relates to
that you know we we could go on and on
but frankly we could spend another two
and a half hours just just speculating
on why cows
um there's a lot of different reasons
reasons why potentially
um you know the fact that it is a
a primary food source for a lot of
people on this planet um you know does
that have something to do with it you
know are they are they
is there something
relevant to that that that that is of
key interest
um i had the privilege of speaking to a
veterinarian
up here in montana of all places
and uh he was a former official
uh and as a veterinarian and it's called
a lot of times to these cattle
mutilations
and he is absolutely 100 convinced that
this is
it is something that is not natural
and that is being done
farmers will report lights in the sky
later on they discover these animals
with uh what appears to be um
cauterization of the wounds
uh a lot of sexual organs
particularly removed
and then some really other unique pieces
to the puzzle where
you know maybe
one tiny bone is missing uh in the
entire animal
and that's it
like it was just removed for the sake of
removing it and studying it and
so uh yeah i mean it's it's something
that's interesting that's been around
for a while um
you know a lot a lot of people
you're not the first to ask me that
that's for sure
sr asks not sure if this has been asked
has lou ever heard of zimmer knocked
whistleblower
the zimmer
zimmer knocked whistleblower
called exactly that or under any other
name appearing on reddit and if yes is
there any truth to it at all
well i don't read reddit
um very often um again if uh if if i
want to abuse myself i'll just get on
twitter um they do a great job doing it
i don't need any more
and then second of all uh no zimmer i am
not not aware of um i'm not familiar
with that unless there's some sort of
vernacular
uh that
it's is also referencing that i i have
no idea about that
stogen carlusic asks what does
lou think of the set of documents named
allies of humanity
uh
i've read a lot of documents i don't
necessarily know about allies of
humanity
what that is unless it is uh
something involves different species
that have been alleged to exist i i i
i don't know i don't know what that is
matt wants to know
what are this goes back to the worms
asking which dirt humans eat yeah
that's a great analogy by the way
so what questions are only the very best
dirt
what questions
should we as the audience as myself
perhaps even as you which questions
should we be asking that we
aren't man well
you're doing it this is it this is
exactly why we're having this
conversation right to figure that out
um
so earlier when you were saying that we
have some unstated assumptions we have
boxes
yeah you're not saying that you're
immune from that you're saying no no i
need your help too
to break out of that no i'm not
absolutely i'm not immune to it no
absolutely not i have the same bias as
everybody else right um no this is
something we need to figure out
collectively no i'm not this is not a
trick question i'm asking you to say
haha the answer no no i'm i've got the
same challenge you do we're in the same
boat
um we need to figure this out and and
this is why i say we need academics and
scientists and everybody else on board
because and philosophers and everybody
because they're the ones that are going
to help us figure
how to do that you know i'm i'm just a
dude i'm just one guy
i'm you know i might not be
super dumb but i'm not necessarily the
smartest guy either i i don't
you're extremely bright man it's
humbling
uh
i appreciate it but no i can assure you
you might
speaking about humbling when you mention
the word sober and somber
that
to me the reason why is because not
because we're more special than we think
we are but we're much less so then i was
wondering hmm is perhaps another
motivation for people that wolf pack
around you not just a financial
motivation not just national security
but also perhaps self-preservation
because absolutely self-preservation
okay
yes that's a huge part of it in fact it
also goes to pride and ego and
self-preservation i mean these are these
are innate components of of the human
psyche
and we need to be aware of it and and a
lot of people don't even realize they're
that way um
you know it it it it comes from a place
of self-preservation ultimately survival
you know um
control um
and to some degree even resources um
it's
it's almost part of our character um we
you look at any any type of society
whether you have
a society where you have a monarchy
a king or a queen making authoritative
decisions
or even to some degree presidents or you
know uh
popes and
you know
again i'm not against any of this i'm
just simply saying that we as a species
we always we always want answers we
always want someone to to have the final
say in narrative because we like we like
our our life to be defined when you look
at the way an average city is city
organizer reason why we make our streets
and grids north and south east and west
because subconsciously it helps us know
where we are at any given time why we
have a compass right what time look even
a watch tells us where we are in time
right we we are a species that doesn't
like we fear the unknown
and when you look at carl sagan's
pale blue dot for the very first time
and you realize that everything in
existence that we know of has occurred
on that tiny little pill blue dot
uh which is you know three pixels large
in the vastness of vacuum of space in
just one ray of light from the sun
that makes people pretty uncomfortable
you know uh
the fact that you know other than
towards the center of the earth there's
no such thing as up or down
there's really no such thing as left for
if you go
far enough you come back right again
uh up is relative
you know up just means i'm moving away
from the center of the earth that's all
there is no real up or down you know we
don't know if we're if we're flying
sideways somewhere in the milky way in
the universe or if we're upside down or
what if there is there's no upside down
there's no
my point is that
when you really look at the universe for
what it is um
we have no idea where we are
none um
we are spinning in an obscure spiral arm
of some obscure galaxy we happen to call
the milky way that's on a collision
course with another galaxy called
andromeda uh next 250 million years or
so
uh but in reality we have no idea where
the hell we are or where we're going or
where we've been
and and so we we build these anecdotes
and histories and whatnot because
it helps us make sense from nonsense and
that's that's what we like as human
beings we don't that's why when you put
people in a solid white room or even the
furniture's white
most people report not only being
disoriented but being uncomfortable
because there's no point of of of
of there's no relativity within the
relativeness within the within that
relative relativeness within the within
the room
um in fact it it that's why death is is
so scary for so many people because it's
the great unknown
um and it's it's something that as a
species we
we fear um
a lot
and and you know it's it's part of
nobody wants to know that they're lost
nobody nobody wants to know that's why
safety and security is so important a
lot of a lot of relationships right
people will say i just want i just want
safety and security that's all i want to
know that that person is going to be
there for me and i can rely upon them
right they want stability they want they
want an anchor
um and that's not a bad thing that
that's who we are
but we also have to realize there's a
lot of things in this universe you know
that that are gonna
gonna force you to reevaluate and that's
really really uncomfortable once you
really realize that you are truly we are
alone
out here in the universe from a from a
human perspective right i'm not saying
from a living thing or a
you know i'm saying from a human
perspective
um you know
that's scary for a lot of people um you
know this isn't to our knowledge we are
the only humans in in the universe and
of course we have a bunch of animals we
can play with on our little planet that
we call earth and you know kind of makes
kind of makes us feel good but but it's
looking more and more
like every single day that there's
there's there's more out there it's just
not human and then the question is okay
well what are their intentions what are
the motivations do they want to work
with us or do they want to subjugate us
um or are we going to be tomorrow's uh
dinner menu right all these things go
through the minds of people
and and they're they're they're you know
they're good questions
and what and questions frankly we don't
have an answer for yet and that makes
people really really uncomfortable and
unsettled and i think we need to be
aware of it so back to your question
what
you know
am i am i subject to the same
box bias that you are and everybody else
you're damn right i am yeah and we need
to figure out how how to look at this
topic
look at a potentially a non-human topic
through non-human eyes is what i'm
trying to say
we may have to take our glasses our
human glasses off
um that kind of filter how do we do that
in terms well that's my question right
how do we do that
this is exactly why we're having this
conversation what can people be doing
having that conversation exactly
that's exactly what what we could be
doing can i add what you said if you
don't mind like a 30 second yeah
it's on point hopefully this pale blue
dot
which i imagine is something i don't
know about it i imagine it's zooming out
and seeing how insignificant we are
relative so let me tell you the pale
blue dot there's a couple there's a
couple pictures that have really really
if you really want to look at something
that's pretty amazing
the first image is called the pill blue
dot um
carl sagan um as the i think it was a
voyager might have been a pioneer i
think it was a voyager spacecraft was
leaving
um
earth's orbit it uh by by somewhere
around the moon it turned around took a
picture of the earth
and then as it was billions and billions
of miles away as it's about to leave the
the uh
the solar system so to speak it's
actually the inner solar system but it
was but you know to the best of our
knowledge at the time it was the solar
system
this is before the heliosphere and
whatnot um
the sp he had a great idea said why
don't we turn that spacecraft around and
take one more picture of earth see what
it looks like
and so he did
and he turned it around and that he
didn't the nasa turned it around took a
picture of earth and at first i couldn't
find it until one scientist pointed out
what's that
and
and you should look it up on google uh
it's it's it's pretty amazing look at it
with with the original photo not zoomed
in
um and and you all of a sudden get this
sense of
um
vastness and and
most will agree maybe a little even a
little insecurity because you're like oh
that's a
that's a fragile little tiny ball in the
middle of nowhere
uh and then another picture is uh taken
by um
it was the
lunar orbiter uh it might have been the
apollo 11
mission
where they're rendezvouing with the uh
with the lunar lander and in there
there's a picture of the lunar lander
with a picture of earth behind it
and in that picture you realize for the
first time that all of humanity
everything that has ever existed
everything that anybody had ever hoped
dreamed or wished for
every war
every famine every crisis
every human being that ever lived
an animal and living thing that we knew
of was all contained in that one picture
except for one person
and that was the one human being taking
that picture from the lunar orbiter
and that's very humbling
because then you realize you know
wow we really are are all into this
together and and you know we
better for us we're we're a family we're
a community
um
and um
you know those are the two pictures i i
would recommend people take a look at
those
for me that was very impactful you know
they say a picture is worth a thousand
words well in this case a picture is
worth five billion people um pretty
pretty interesting
let me play with that if i can do so for
a little bit and let me see if i can say
this
i haven't articulated this out loud
but when people show there's some
youtube videos that show the vastness of
space how immense it is just keep
zooming out zooming in and out in and
out i mean out and out and out and
outward and then some people feel dread
and meaningless but
to me that
that seems like it seems like a relic of
territorial domination when we used to
tell a country's
power or stature from how much it owned
because what difference does it make if
we're one percent of one percent of one
percent spatially or temporally of the
galaxy
all of what matters maybe that's not
what matters at all maybe space and time
being located in it isn't what matters
if it was then we could go to the
holocaust and say well it doesn't matter
because look at how small of a region it
is and how temporally bounded it was and
say so it doesn't matter but it matters
you're the birth of your daughter
matters the everything that the death of
your son matters every single thing that
matters
is bounded temporally and spatially so
perhaps what matters most isn't how much
space do we take up but maybe it's our
heart
maybe it's our capacity for pain
maybe it's
the ability to show love despite being
hurt and to trust again
maybe that all in from another realm is
something it's huge maybe it's vastly
huge in the way that we look at
ourselves as small maybe it's huge in to
make an analogy in the realm of
consciousness if it's a space like space
and time but
we don't know and in fact all that we do
know is what matters isn't
like your favorite piece of music it's
not it's only three four five ten
minutes long it's not an infinite amount
of time
so i well kurt the value of a human
being again may not be what's up in here
and the body it may be that that piece
that we talked about before right that
that indelible part of the human that
that is hard to define whether you call
it a spirit or whatever you want to call
it you know a soul
um you're right and i i think i think
there's that's the value of a human
being it's not that two dollars and
three cents worth of carbon that my
body's worth right right right
nine pounds or so of my brain or maybe
in my case much less weight
you know but um it's it's there's
something else that that creates the
value for a human being but you know
i've said this before and let me
reiterate this first anybody who hasn't
heard this yet you know we talk about
the human being
being this small moment of occupying the
small moment of space in this infinitely
vast you know 92 billion light year gala
universe across from side to side
and yet
and yet within every single human being
curt is almost in an equal amount of
space what do i mean well let's look at
an atom 1 times 10 to the negative 26.
when you compare that to the human body
you know we are that universe we are
that vastness we are to the atom we are
the universe
and we are just as business
right and so
we really sit in right in the middle
of the scale of the universe and that's
important because it as big as the
universe outside is it's just as big
inside
and and you know we're just now
beginning to explore the realities of
that and what that means um
and so
you know there's there's beauty in that
but of course for a lot of people
there's a lot of discomfort right and
uncertainty right and insecurity
so um
so yeah i get it man i i i understand
it's it's um
it's one of those things that that you
know
ultimately we're wrestling ourselves why
are we so insecure
and why does this topic make us so
insecure well because
we're forced to look in the mirror and
question ourselves
and
reconcile the fact that we really don't
know where we are and we really don't
know where we're going despite the best
and the brightest in our in our
governments that we appoint and say yes
we are giving you the the uh the
authority to to tell us things right but
in reality it's kind of an illusion um
it's just like
money the only reason why money means
anything is because we've all
made a moral contract to agree that yes
it's valued but it doesn't really have
value it's piece of paper there's no
real intrinsic value behind it other
than we've all agreed to the illusion
that yeah it means something
well it's the same thing with with
governments and authority and some
religions you know that we we have
invested this this authority
to
to tell us as a species give us answers
give us meaning right
so you think those at the top feel
insecure that they may not have the
answers oh well they they don't a lot of
them don't have the answers it's not
they don't
we know they don't and and i think if
they were to be true themselves they
know they don't
know
i mean look at look at people if you
think they do do you think that they
think that they have answers or do you
feel like they know they don't think
deep enough to even recognize it i think
they think they have answers for the
paradigm for which they are living it
they don't understand that there's a
much bigger
reality there for their little reality
that's been conceived and painted for
them yes they're coloring within the
boundaries of the of the of the of the
lines like me when i take notes in this
book um you know i i i can i'm confining
my notes only to the limit boundaries of
the paper right that's all i can have to
write with um some
people are those notes classified and
you just revealed some classif
classifiers no no no no never classified
screenshot then zoom in yeah
i think um you know that's uh for me
um you know i look at it that way some
people just have a bigger notepad to
write notes
um
you know
but maybe we get to a point where we
realize that even that we need a notepad
is is i'm getting very esoteric or maybe
the fact that we're even using a notepad
is limiting us maybe
the key here is that you know
maybe we need to get rid of notepads
altogether doesn't matter how big of a
notepad you have because you know you're
never going to be able to contain all
the information in in a notepad
that's one of the claims of anjali is
that we need to get past the limitations
of language for whatever reason the
aliens have told her this and that we
need to start communicating
telepathically or realize the
limitations of language
just as an aside
well i'm not sure you need aliens to
tell you that i think that's you know
that's that's something age old man has
known for a long time
uh you know
yet old cliche right well i love you
beyond words well what does that mean
we're limited by language you know
language is a close as we can get right
now to reading each other's minds but at
the end of the day we're still limited
you know but i don't i definitely don't
need aliens necessarily to tell me that
that's such a kind of
that's kind of a
reality for us i think
okay getting back to some of these i
know that you're all eager kevin lands
down asked given the clues lou de long
and others have been laying down it
seems like we're dealing with crypto
terrestrials not necessarily aliens
is this what admiral byrd found during
operation high jump
it's absolutely possible that this is
something that's been on been on this
planet for a very long time and it's
just as natural to to
to earth as we are it could very well be
its own you know this is crazy as may
sound it could be its own animal kingdom
you know just like the hidden world of
of protozoa and what not of the
microorganisms and that animal kingdom
that was invisible to us until just a
couple hundred years ago
uh
could be you know um
the likelihood of it i i don't really
know but it's def i mean it is a
possibility you can't you can't say no
umix asks can you ask him about project
crystal knight aka project serpo which
was featured at the end of steven
spielberg's close encounter
um
i am not
familiar enough with it to speak in any
type of authoritative way um it'd be
pure speculation so um
just i'll leave it unfortunately i wish
i could answer it for you
matt wood asks have you had you lou have
you had any holy [ __ ] moments
where you learned a truth about
something so over the top that it wasn't
even on your question list speaking of
question lists
oh yeah
okay let me continue then so you have
more to riff off of how many times have
extraordinary relevance occurred to you
as you were learning about this
phenomenon
so as it relates to uap um there were a
few i'm i'm beginning to put my thoughts
down on paper um
there were there were
there were quite a few um
and um
you know each time it challenged my my
my perspective on things it challenged
my
my
my understanding of the universe and our
place in it um
but uh
not quite yet prepared to have that
conversation uh but but i i will have it
at some point
did you ever lose sleep over it
all the time
gus baja asks if lou is under nda
how can he write a book with new and
definitive information regarding the uap
phenomena
i don't think this question is meant to
be snarky at all i think it's genuine
yeah it's got to go through a security
review process
and my intent is to put everything i can
down there and then whatever the
government decides uh no different than
lecatsky whatever the government decides
to redact and you're going to know
what's redacted you're going to know
what parts are redacted and what parts
are not uh
and um you know you gotta try but it's
not my call i've got to get it reviewed
so you know how can i well i
i can by going through the right
processes and and that's how you do it
there's a right way and a wrong way to
do it so i intend to do it the right the
right way
how long does that process take
when you're getting a bucket it's not
after me can be can be can be a while um
you know but that's
that's what i'm gonna do
and i've got a great partnership with
with harpercollins who who is is you
know willing to take this journey so
and by the way there'll be a very
specific reason very obvious when when
that book comes out a lot of people are
are making uh presumptions and
assumptions of of my motivation they
haven't a clue they have no clue what
i'm doing
it'll be very quick what will be obvious
be crystal clear of why i'm writing this
book
when it comes out
people are gonna go oh wow so
jesus is the light asks one question for
lou i've never heard this one asked if
uaps are trying to prevent us from
nuclear war that supposedly may happen
in the future now this is
predicated on a future human hypothesis
when
was this supposed to take place is it
less than 10 years from now
obviously we're in wild speculative
territory i mean we don't know they're
trying to prevent a nuclear war
that's that's again
a presumption by by some people you know
let's let's not forget that in russia
they actually turned them on so that you
know
i don't know if that's preventing an
ignore and by the way if that's the case
they didn't prevent us dropping a bomb
on hiroshima and nagasaki so you know
there's there's already flawed logic
there that they're trying to prevent
anything we don't know that we are
presuming um so we need to be very
careful with that as far as any type of
future war your guess is as good as mine
um you know uh that's
that's that's a whole different
territory that i'm
i'm not uh
i'm definitely not qualified to answer
okay this is a question that i've
thought about
wiley lafferty asks
who are the government people that come
to confiscate cameras and data
threatening witnesses to remain silent
about their experience this has happened
to military and civilian witnesses
he says atep question mark
no it wasn't a chip i mean no it wasn't
egypt but but yeah there were people who
definitely
who definitely uh try to intimidate
people and um you know all i gotta say
is you know i
that wouldn't be wise to do it with me
and my colleagues um
you know i
i don't get intimidated very easily um
you know we're kind of the people who if
if you focus we're going to poke you
right back
um
you know
i i don't know why people got
intimidated in the past um
you know the only way i would ever shut
up from this is someone really came in
and said luke we need you to
to be quiet this is hurting national
security but that hasn't happened
um
you know i'm the kind of guy if you try
to intimidate me your
you're making a big big mistake
um and i'll leave it at that because my
background is is specific enough where
um you better come at me with everything
you got
is there any truth to men in black
well i mean sure the question is who are
they you know there's been elements in
the past where
you know u.s investigators um i mean the
truth is we wear black suits sometimes i
mean i have three of them you know um
the problem is that hollywood is kind of
portrayed a certain way
um
you know for us you know black suits
were fairly functional you could you
could look i mean this is gonna sound
silly but you know you wear them because
they're like wearing jeans but formal
attire because you can spill food on
black suits and all that kind of stuff
and kind of wipe it away and you know
it's a little bit more forgiving than
another type of suit um
so and historically they tend to be more
the cheaper suits um just because
they're black they're not you know
really fancy material or stuff like that
so historically black suits have always
been messed with government
and and you know what people refer to us
as government stiffs um
there's always been men in black you
know
i was one of them was counterintelligent
special agent but
i never intimidated intimidated people
like that um and so the question is
who's doing that and and why are they
doing that and under whose authority are
they doing that
that's my problem you know if they're
operating with without any authority
then you know
[Music]
you got problems
you know because you know we had to all
operate under under rules and
authorities and if you're not and you're
running rogue and you're going around
intimidating people you know i i can't
stand bullies man i i i'm i don't like
bullies i'm not that guy anybody who
knows about the way i was raised and
what i had to go through
you know i tend to be a bit of an
anti-bully um i tend to try
yeah you know that's that's
that's kind of or put the bullies in
their place
yeah you know they weren't going to be
bullies much longer i can assure you um
so anyways with that said
kurt unfortunately i'm getting blown up
here um to i guess i'm late by six
minutes uh for another
interview i hate to be um hey i'd love
to keep talking about this
time with your your folks
um hopefully i didn't waste anybody's
time i know you're going to get people
saying oh they've been in for me with
june i know lou avoided this and that
i'm sorry in advance they're going to do
it they've got some haters they're just
going to
they're going to nail you on it uh but
you know i'd love to do this again with
the end if there's anything
i haven't addressed you know let's let's
let's do it next time
thank you man i appreciate your
generosity again immense generosity
and as well as for what you're doing
well and i appreciate what you're doing
and i appreciate what your audience is
doing because you guys are making the
difference you know you keep asking me
what can you do you're doing it this is
exactly what you can do and so you're
doing it better than anybody else so so
thank you
take care man
you got it take care folks and i'm sorry
i had to leave like this but
i i do have another
no problem no problem i apologize okay
take care everybody until next time
yes sir take care
okay now let me take a look at the
comments
and thank you all you all are saying
thank you so frequently thank you thank
you all thank you easter thank you matt
thank you taylor thank you tanya thank
you eric
thank you pix thank you fetus or
festus krusty thank you let me think if
there
are announcements there's an audio
version of the podcast so there's itunes
spotify google podcasts
pandora and so on if you check the links
in the description of any of the videos
if you're interested in supporting this
podcast
just so you know the patrons and the
sponsors are the only ones that are what
allow me to do this full time
so if you would like to then you're more
than welcome to go to patreon.com
kurtjmungle the link to all of that is
it's in virtually every video so you can
click the description there
and support even a dollar
there are custom pledges people want to
know some people want to donate more
some people want to donate less and
there is a way to custom pledge if
you're if you want to
there is no incentive for the patrons
and i'd like to keep it that way what i
mean by that is that you don't get a cup
you don't get oh by the way speaking of
merch there's toe merch i'm going to
talk about that
you don't get a cup you don't get access
to episodes sooner or ad free you are
simply doing so to support the channel
and show your love so if you would like
to do that again that's patreon.com
slash curt gym uncle c-u-r-t-j-a-i
m-u-n-g-a-l
and there's no
thank you regardless
okay as for the merch there's tow merch
for the first time
theories of everything merch and that's
until the end of october i'll include
the link right here
if you're interested
until the end of october 2021 there's
the first ever theories of everything
merch at the link in the description or
you can visit tinyurl.com
tow merch t-o-e-m-e-r-c-h
dylan you asked if i could ask your
super chat next time i will remember
your name dylan 808
you need toe socks merch there are
they're kirk kirkhouse there is toe
socks merch so there's two types of toe
socks one that says toe and then one
that says toe clippings in case you
don't want to watch two hours
three hour four hour five hour long
conversations some of our podcasts the
longest seven hours if you don't want to
watch that which many people don't have
the time in fact they feel a sense of
consternation looking at the length of
the podcast
there there's a channel called toe
clippings
which has
anywhere from one to ten minutes clips
when when will lou be back on that's
when lou decides to be back on i'll have
him on virtually any time he'd like to
come on
okay so i should get going i'm fairly
tired and
those who are sticking around are
sticking around maybe because they are
interested in the behind the scenes of
the channel
so if you are here's a little
behind the scenes
i
i plan on still going at it full force
and
i don't mind if i burn myself out
which it's seeming more and more likely
as each day that goes by because on
november 2nd or so i'm pretty much
taking
a month or two months off
perhaps starting november 3rd
so i'm gonna go at it full force the
next round of podcasts i have the list
here they are luis elisondo i will
likely be doing an ama on
sunday so you can watch that live
michael levin is also coming out
carlo ravelli which is a theoretical
physicist stefan alexander another
theoretical physicist
and then i'm being interviewed on
several platforms like ufo singularity
podcast
greg henriques has a podcast called
universal theory of knowledge i believe
so i'll be on that garrett vanderburgh
vandenberg has a podcast so i'll be out
on that so quite a bit
happening and then someone fairly large
which i'm not allowed to announce
i'll be on
his or her podcast and so preparing for
that is quite
daunting someone matt you want to know
if any of the questions were
screened by lou none i don't think a
single one
i think there was one question i was
going to send him and ask him is it okay
if i ask you this but that was my
question and i didn't end up doing so
lastly i said that i would read aloud
all the super chats however there are
far too many to read and so what i'll do
instead is place a link in the
description to a reddit thread where
i've copied and pasted each of the super
chats next time that i speak with lou
these will get priority the podcast is
now finished if you'd like to support
conversations like this then do consider
going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you